[Musique]
philippe bihouix bon soir dans ça vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle singer view on vous reçoit
dans le cadre de votre activité de votre
bouquin sur les low tech qu'est ce que
vous faites dans la vie est ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement
alors dans la vie dans la vraie vie je
suis ingénieur je travaille dans une
grande société et donc je fais de
société
une société de transport public
ferroviaire d'accord qui est souvent
alors qu est souvent alors voilà pas
seulement mais pas dans la partie
passage et donc non bâti syntsha casque
vous en passer
et qu'est ce qui vous a amené à vous
intéresser sur l'épuisement débit tous
les lots technologie ces choses là mais
il ya une quinzaine d'années en fait je
travaillais dans le dans le conseil
quand c'est en stratégie et en
organisation
dans un cabinet américain au
franco-américain est donc
je me suis intéressé en travaillant chez
différents clients industriels à ces
questions là la question des ressources
non renouvelables c'est à dire ce qu'on
pioche dans le stock de la croûte
terrestre et au gré comme ça des années
je vois là je glane est des choses sur
comment on fait des engrais comment on
fait un avion comment on fait des
télécoms etc et est arrivé à la fin de
la décennie 2000 la gigantesque
accélération notamment de la chine qui a
propulsé donc des matières premières
pétrole mais aussi métaux comme le
cuivre etc à des sommets et à ce moment
là dans le dans le cadre de mes
activités de conseil j'ai eu l'occasion
de m'emparer des sujets un peu de
développement durable on va dire ou des
questions d'exposition matières
premières ça a fait que j'ai creusé le
sujet encore plus que ce que je faisais
ça a fini par donner un premier livre
qui a été publié en 2010 quel futur pour
les métaux qui m'a propulsé semi
spécialiste mondial français des
ressources décentes et non plus me
l'avait tellement peu voilà donc je me
suis retrouvé invité à différents types
de différents types de deux colloques ou
d'un temps à bassam est amené à faire
quelques interventions à gauche à droite
j'ai rencontré des gens aussi ça m'a
donné envie de faire un livre un tout
petit peu plus grand public donc l'âge
des low tech et qui dénonce la question
de croissance verte c'est de course en
avant technologique à cause justement de
cette question des ressources non
renouvelables
donc ces ressources non renouvelables
dans un biotope économiques tels que le
doute 21e siècle qu'est ce que ça donne
à moyen terme alors ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle moyen terme évidemment temps
alors bon pour donc la première chose
c'est de dire que effectivement n'a pas
qu'un problème d'énergie ou un problème
de climat on a aussi un problème de
ressources parce que quand bien même on
aurait une énergie des milliers de fois
supérieure à ce que l'on consomme il
faut malheureusement des ressources
métallique souvent pour convertir pour
stocker pour utiliser cette énergie donc
on tape dans un stock qui est forcément
limitée il peut être très important il
est d'ailleurs très important mais voilà
il se trouve que priori à moins de se
démontrer tous ensemble qu'on va aller
le chercher dans d'autres choses dans
les astéroïdes dans les planètes ou
voilà pour y revenir éventuellement
parce qu'il ya déjà des gens qui sont
sur ces questions là il ya des gens qui
pensent à faire du de l'astéroïde mining
etc ouais
donc à moi de faire ça on est dans un
stock finissent tôt finie ça veut dire
qu'à un moment ou un autre on va passer
par un pic de production n'a pas le
choix parce qu'il finira bien par faire
zéro alors la question c'est quand
est-ce que ce pic de production peu
peuvent apparaître ou pas il se trouve
que jusqu'à présent tous les inquiétudes
malthusienne on pourrait dire on est et
on était toujours repoussée repoussé
d'une part parle parler découverte
géologique supplémentaires alors un
moment je ne sais pas à la fin du
moyen-age on finit par pu avoir beaucoup
d'argent en argent métal en europe plus
du tout d'or d'ailleurs parce qu'on
faisait des échanges avec avec l'afrique
et puis ben heureusement on découvre le
nouveau monde et à ce moment là on peut
aller chercher l'argent au pérou au
mexique etc donc il ya toujours une
possibilité de d'élargir les endroits où
on va chercher et on commence l'année
prochaine normalement il va y avoir une
une première exploitation sous marine
par exemple au large de la papouasie
nouvelle guinée pour de l'or et quelques
autres métaux on peut imaginer que dans
le futur je sais pas on aille exploiter
l'antarctique par exemple on savait que
c'était le continent gondwana il ya des
choses en australie il ya des choses en
amérique du sud dont il ya des choses en
antarctique sous quelques kilomètres de
glace pour l'instant mais voilà donc on
peut toujours améliorer ça
ensuite la question technologique la
technologie progresse on est capable
aujourd'hui d'attaquer si je puis dire
ou d'exploiter des minerais qui sont
bien moins concentrés qu'ils ne
l'étaient 20 30 40 50 cent tentes
plusieurs siècles on serait jamais
rentré dans l'âge du cuivre et l'âge du
bronze s'il avait fallu si nos ancêtres
avaient dû exploiter le cuivre à 0 8% de
concentration comme aujourd'hui et puis
il ya un troisième élément c'est
l'élément prix c'est à dire que si le
prix augmente c'est bien mécaniquement
les réserves ce qu'on peut exploiter
augmente aussi alors voilà vous savez
une mine d'or dans une mine d'or vous
allez remet une tonne de minerai pour
sortir de 1 à 5 grammes d'or à peu près
tandis que dans la même tonne de minerai
n'y mine de cuivre crachera 8 à 15 kg de
cuivre et une mine de fer 400 kg et 400
kg 10 kg 3 g pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
se permettre de remuer une tonne de
roche pour sortir 3 g parce qu'on est
prêt à payer lors plus cher que le
cuivre et le cuivre plus cher que le
faire donc mécaniquement un peu comme
dans le pétrole d'ailleurs pourquoi est
ce qu'on a toujours 40 ans devant nous
vint ces deux là même c'est la même
chose on progresse on en avait
découverte géologique on progresse en
technologie ont fait des choses avec du
pétrole non conventionnels les gaz non
conventionnel etc et il ya la question
du prix qui intervient aussi donc tout
ça malheureusement c'est déjà compliqué
sur le pétrole vers et d'essayer de
savoir effectivement quand est ce qu'il
y aura un pic ou pas et il est il est
passé il n'est pas passé en
conventionnel pour conventionnelle sur
les métaux c'est la même chose mais x
60m conclut complexité qui est multiplié
par le nombre de métaux différents
sachant que les mines sont très souvent
polymétallique donc on va trouver un peu
d'or un peu d'argent dans des mines de
cuivre par exemple on va exploiter
l'argent dans les mines de plomb zinc il
ya plein de gars comme ça et on a en
plus une question supplémentaire par
rapport à la question de du pétrole
puisque le pétrole je sors le baril jeu
le brûle et à moins de transformer
entraînement marginalement en plastique
ne finira pas le brûler sa terminera
dans l'atmosphère ça nous pose
d'ailleurs quelques problèmes
climatiques
pour les pour les métaux sa marque
différemment ses terres ce que la dgrad
de cuivre d'or que j'ai extrait je les
ai pas perdu en les utilisant en fait
ils sont toujours là ils sont dans le
stock de la technosphère de l'entrepôt
ce faire on pourrait me revoilà donc
dans les objets autour de nous donner
les smartphones les voitures des
bâtiments et on peut recycler donc du
coup il ya aussi la composante du
recyclage qui intervient c'est à dire
que plus jure aussi que évidemment moi
je vais avoir besoin de taper rapidement
dans le stock et donc plus j'ai loigne
potentiellement le le risque de pénurie
ou le risque de le risque de pic c'est
donc ça
cette grosse différence qui fait dire
finalement au tenant de la croissance
verte de l'économie circulaire
réaffirmant les ressources non
renouvelables et métaux ne sont pas un
problème parce qu'on va recycler on va
recycler à l'infini et le fait est que
les métaux ont cet avantage parham par
exemple sur les plastiques avec les
plastiques m'ont tous les plastiques se
recyclent pas mais du plastique qui sert
aux cycles on va au bout de quelques
quelques cycles justement 3 4 5 6 7
parfois on finit par casser les
molécules et c'est encore la qualité se
dégrade c'est pas le cas pour les métaux
les métaux ont peu refondre lingots de
cuivre on va refaire un gourcuff qui
aura exactement les mêmes les mêmes
capacités d'accord donc du coup cette
cette économie circulaire elle est
théoriquement possible ça fonctionne
aussi tu en argent l'argent métal oui
oui absolument mais tout à fait vous
pouvez garder vos pièces d'argent mais
ce buzz de 5 francs sous votre oreiller
mulet recul c'est dur voulez oui alors
savon après ya effectivement la question
de la prime sur la pièce mais oui il ya
aucun problème alors il va y avoir ce
qu'on appelle quand même une potentielle
en une perte au feu que quand vous
refonder quelque chose dont il rien ne
se perd rien ne se crée un on est
d'accord mais il voit là mais vous allez
avoir bon voilà quelques molécules de ci
de là qui seront partis dans
l'atmosphère ou ailleurs donc on a du
mal à recycler à 100% ya rien qui car
rendement de 100 % dans la vraie vie on
va peut-être à
99,99 ça serait déjà très bien problème
c'est que la manière dont ils utilisent
aujourd'hui nos métaux mais absolument
pas ne nous permet absolument pas
d'atteindre des taux de recyclage de ce
type là alors à quelques exceptions près
le plomb qui utilisait principalement
dans les batteries de voiture est très
bien recyclés parce qu'il ya des impacts
environnementaux dont il ya un enjeu
réglementaire derrière ça c'est une
filière de business to business donc
c'est facile de récupérer en fin de vie
les et les gens ne balance plus ou plus
trop leurs batteries sur les bords des
routes les amène plutôt en déchetterie
donc c'est recyclé 4 99% dans un pays
dans un pays comme le nôtre par contre
il ya déjà beaucoup de métaux qui le
contraire atteignent des taux de
recyclage extrêmement faibles notamment
des métaux emblématique des nouvelles
technologies en je suis pas sûr que je
vais vous assénez j'ai des noms de
poudre de perlimpinpin on pourrait citer
pas en ligne homme qui sert dans les
écrans plein
l'auxine d'hommes et un c'est ce qui
permet d'avoir une couche conductrice et
transparentes donc dans tous les dans
tout ce qui est tactile où vous allez
vous avez de lignum le gallium qui a un
peu les mêmes propriétés tout ce qui est
très rare alors cette erreur sont pas
forcément rare ça une dénomination qui a
du xixème siècle tout ça s'est recyclé à
moins de 1% -2 1% pourquoi s'est recyclé
aussi peu en fait il ya deux phénomènes
qui empêche le recyclage correct comme
le plomb à 99% le premier c'est ce que
j'ai appelé les usages dispersif août
dissipatifs c'est à dire qu'on n'utilise
pas forcément les métaux sous une forme
métalliques simples qu'on va récupérer
en fin de vie pour la recycler c'est la
fourchette voilà que j'ai mis dans voilà
je referai une fourchette après on fait
ça on a de nombreux métaux qui sont
utilisés alors je peux vous citer
quelques exemples tout ce qui est
additifs dans les cosmétiques on a
trouvé des métaux 1/3 du titane entre du
zinc vous savez que le titane c'est le
col rond de langue universelle
donc il ya 95% du thème qui est utilisé
sous cette forme là donc on ne peut pas
recycler par définition mais vous avez
trouvez vous allez trouver du cobalt qui
sert à faire du bleu du chrome qui ça va
faire du jaune et du vin etc dans les
peintures les feux d'artifice les tissus
dans lé cuir pour le pur talent et les
cuirs et c'est tard il ya toute une
toute une gamme d usage comme ça qui ne
sont pas recyclables et sans même parler
de pièces qui s'usent un jeu dire si
elle en parlait tout à l'heure de
ferroviaire brrr si vous prenez la lame
d'un pantographe en cuivre ben ils
courent sur la caténaire et voilà elle
s'use et de temps en temps il faut les
changer même assez souvent donc ce
cuivre n'est pas perdu à nouveau reine
se permet il a été dispersée il a été
dispersé dans l'environnement alors ça
peut être parce que vous vous êtes laver
les mains voila je prends une pièce de
monnaie je vais la jouer là frottés et
ensuite je vais me laver les mains et ça
va partir dans les stations d'épuration
ça va finir soit dans la boue
d'épuration soit dans une rivière puis
dans la mer donc je ne peux pas
récupérer cette partie
la deuxième est fake est en effet un peu
plus embêtant c'est l'effet de la
complexité de nos produits c'est tous
ces métaux les 60 m de repas tout à
l'heure on les utilise assez rarement
sous leur forme pure ça arrive le câble
de cuivre la batterie au plomb dont on
parlait tout à l'heure la pluie voilà
exactement encore que parce que dans les
générals vous avez l'ordre public un
petit peu trop facile à déformer donc en
général on rajoute du palladium le
cuivre d'autres choses pour ce qui est
du cuivre dans le krugerrand sud
africain c'est ça oui c'est pour là
c'est pour l'aspect là effectivement la
dureté de la pièce et donc sa tenue
mécanique effectivement voilà pourquoi
on retrouve quelques couleurs rendent
dans les siècles prochain
donc je vois que vous connaissez bien
voilà donc la complexité et peut prendre
deux formes elle peut prendre la forme d
alliages donc on va avoir des parts des
aciers spéciaux qui vont contenir une
dizaine de trucs un peu bizarres alors
ça peut être du vanadium du titane du
tungstène etc
et puis ou alors vous allez utiliser
dans des en toutes petites quantités
dans des étangs des dents des objets qui
ont été intégrés miniaturisés et plats
typiquement va tomber sur la question
des idées aux technologies vous avez une
cinquantaine de métaux vais pas tout la
table de mendeleïev mais ça y ressemble
dans votre smartphone et qui sont
utilisés en quantité très petit ça peut
être quelques milligrammes ça peut être
bien moins que les mg et malheureusement
quand tout ça va arriver en fin de vie
qu'est ce qui se passe on a des dizaines
de milliers d'alliages différents pas
dire des centaines de milliers ya
évidemment pas des centaines de milliers
de poubelles donc on va faire deux
grosses poubelles une poubelle qu'on
appelle l'acier carbone ou à mettre les
aciers de bas de gamme une poubelle
qu'on appelle les aciers inox dans
laquelle on ramène des choses qui
contiennent du nickel et du chrome en
général et donc ma petite fourchette on
va prendre la fois un mikel de bas de
gamme enfin 1 à 6 contient très peu de
nickel elle va pas partir dans la bonne
poubelle à partir dans la poubelle acier
carbone et ça fera un rond à béton c'est
à dire un ferraillage du bâtiment donc
en fait on a on a bien recyclés
physiquement mais fonctionnellement mon
petit atome de nickel qui m'avait servir
à lutter contre la corrosion à sa
première utilisation quand je l'avais
extrait de la mine
mahi bine terminée dans une ferraille à
béton et ne sera évidemment jamais
récupéré comme tel théoriquement ça
serait possible point de vue énergétique
ça serait une totale aberration
va délier un petit peu l'aspect
technologique du recyclage après
j'aimerais vous poser une question
qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'exploitation des nodules
polymétalliques en eaux profondes
voilà c'est la même chose que les que
les exploitations différentes
exploitations milliard d'abord il ya il
n'y a pas on trouve pas tous dans les
nodules polymétalliques
on trouve du manganèse et puis un
certain nombre d'autres d'autres métaux
mais sûrement pas tous les métaux de la
table de mendeleïev qu'est-ce qu'il a
eue politique qu'est ce qu'un add your
money métallique s'est en fait c'est une
concrétion qui s'est formée en général
autour d'un deux roues tient au fait tu
d'impuretés de départ on va dire sur
laquelle se sont accrochés des atomes
qui était dissous long qui sont dissous
dans l'eau de mer il ya plein de choses
dissoute dans l'autre mère iliad et
l'uranium par exemple est un moment
fontès mais l'imaginé de filtrer l'eau
de mer pour récupérer les graines y
sommes voilà et donc ces nodules i en
fonction de leur taille ils sont plus ou
moins anciens voilà ça me touche parce
que c'est une agression qui va se faire
comme une perle on pourrait dire dans
une huître mais c'est pas les mêmes tout
à fait les mêmes produits chimiques
voilà et donc ces ions 10 où ils vont
plus ou moins bien ceux déposés plus
fusion a facilement donc effectivement
il ya notamment le manganèse il ya deux
du nickel du cobalt toi c'est comment on
va lui chercher alors je voulais juste
préciser qui a pas que les dans les
fantasmes sous marin il n'y a pas que il
n'ya pas que les nodules polymétalliques
est aussi ce qu on appelle les encres
hautement quoi fantasmes alors on va je
lui ai vu des recrutements cobalt y
faire donc c'est des trucs qu'on trouve
autour des cheminées hydrothermales donc
là c'est en fait voilà ça sort de la
lithosphère il ya plein de choses tout
un écosystème si ça il ya effectivement
des éponges des machins des bactéries
qui travaillent la chimie du soufre
plutôt que la chimie du carbone voilà
donc il ya un truc qui se baladent alors
comment on fait ben en fait on va
prendre un gros aspirateur
qu'on va balader au fond de l'eau alors
en gros c'est des techniques qui sont
encore assez prospective mais qui sont
inspirés de l'offshore pétrolier donc
y'a un
bateau d'exploitation et puis ce bateau
exploitations sont accrochés des tubes
qui descendent des bayas les petites
machines qui vont aller ramasser tout ça
donc quel est le problème alors le
problème on pourrait dire d'abord il ya
environnementale potentiellement ce
qu'on connaît rien ce qui se passe où
ces deux 3000 mètres d'eau alors c'est
un problème qu'on pourrait dire lié à
n'importe quelle exploitation minière
parce que faut savoir qu évidemment les
exploitations minières c'est parmi les
les les activités humaines les plus
polluantes on voit là parce que alors il
ya plusieurs manières de faire ça dépend
si les exploitations sont sont
souterraines ou bien sont en open pid ça
dépend un petit peu de bon des critères
environnementaux qu'on va appliquer ou
pas mais d'une manière ou d'une autre en
po1 on va toujours pollués parce qu'il
restera des des résidus miniers dans
lequel il va y avoir des métaux qui ne
s'intéressaient pas où les métalloïdes
comme l'arsenic donc ensuite ça va être
les chais par les autres pluie il faut
faire des bassins des fois ça des fois
ça lâche il ya eu des cas comme ça avant
donc et on modifie le cycle de l'eau
modifie plein de choses donc de toute
manière c'est impacteront alors là c'est
ses impacts ans au carré emploi dire
parce qu'évidemment on ramasse des
nodules pauline des modules qui sont
assez quelques nodule au mètre carré
peut-être pour qu'une les concentrations
les plus forts ont en revanche tout fait
donc combat voilà au lieu de fait donné
des coups de pelle on va aller donner
des coups d'aspirateur alors ça c'est
l'aspect environnemental ensuite on
pourrait dire l'aspect économique
puisque évidemment la question c'est en
fait est ce que tout ça c'est ça peut
être économiquement rentable donc ça
dépend évidemment de la quantité de
métaux vous allez ramasser et du prix
auquel vous pouvez espérer des ventes
donc comme on a aujourd'hui un peu des
choses qui se développe sur la question
du cobalt par exemple qui on a fini par
découvrir que souvent dans les batteries
au lithium y avait du cobalt non quand
sa foi l'un peut alors qu'avant
s'affoler sur le lithium moyens effet de
mode un petit peu comme ça donc voilà
nickel cobalt des nodules
polymétalliques ça va être génial mais
ça des preuves du prix et puis à la
question énergétique c'est à dire que
c'est ça qui rejoint en fait toute la
question des ressources c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est qu'en fait les ressources
on peut toujours aller chercher plus
loin on peut toujours aller chercher
plus profond on peut toujours aller
chercher sous les océans comme je
voulais dit ce n'est qu'une question de
prix à payer si vous acceptez un jour de
que si vous êtes prêt à me payer le prix
pour le cuivre ou le nickel de demain
j'irai vous le cherchez promis jusque
dans le jardin de votre grand mère c'est
juste une question de concentration et
de ce que je vais les chercher on n'a
pas la limite dans les ressources qu'on
peut avoir qu'on a sur la question des
énergies fossiles ou autre d'ailleurs
qui est la question du retour sur
investissement énergétique quand je vais
récupérer un baril de pétrole il faut
pas que j'ai mis au départ un baril de
pétrole en énergie d'exploitation ou en
énergie grise pour construire la
plateforme et ses skis non je fais
tourner la cage à hamster pour rien donc
un bar il doit me rapporter plus qu'un
baril est d'ailleurs malheureusement ce
taux est le taux de retour sur
investissement énergétique se dégradent
puisque justement il faut aller chercher
de plus en plus profondément ou des
choses qui sont bien moins accessible
bien plus difficiles à extraire que les
pétroles onshore deschamps super géant
découvert dans les années 30 à 60 dans
le golfe persique quoi et en arabie
saoudite
donc dans le dans l'est les ressources
métallique on n'a pas cette contrainte
là j'ai pas j'ai pas une barrière qui
est de dire ah là là j'ai investi trois
bien trois barils de pétrole contre un
kilo de cuivre ça vaut plus coup non si
je suis ici j'ai besoin de ce cuivre et
que je suis prêt à mettre la quantité
d'énergie nécessaire
j avoue le chercher quelle que soit
la teneur donc évidemment nos ancêtres
étaient pas stupides ils ont commencé
par taper à la pioche avec énergie
wilson voilà eric quelques scènes dans
ce qui était le plus simple et
accessible on continue à faire ça parce
que il ya aucune raison aujourd'hui
qu'une entreprise minière si elle a deux
possibilités l attaque un plutôt que
l'autre elle atteindra celui pour la
même quantité de deux camions pour la
quantité de pelleteuse pour une quantité
de salaire etc qui va me rapporter le
plus donc on a une concentration qui est
en baisse parce que chaque fois qu'une
mine ferme et qui a une mine qui ouvre
pour accompagner la croissance ou
remplacer la fermeture de la mine la
concentration de la nouvelle mine elle
est plus basse que la précédente voilà
donc on a le problème on n'a pas de
problème a priori sauf que tu faut
accepter de payer le prix et payer le
prix c'est mettre plus d'énergie puisque
bien entendu pour sortir avant même mon
kg de cuivre je vais devoir remuer plus
de roche de terre ou alors aller les
chercher au fond de l'océan et la
question c'est donc ça et j'ai besoin de
plus d'énergie pour aller chercher des
métaux qui vont se raréfier c'est à dire
qu'ils vont devenir qui sont
prolifiques mais de plus en plus
difficile à aller chercher et à l'
inverse j'ai une énergie qui elle aussi
soit se raréfient soit en tout cas se
renchérit dans son côté métallique c'est
à dire que malheureusement parce
qu'elles sont intermittentes parce
qu'elles sont moins concentrés look on
n'arrive à ce qu'il faut les stocker les
énergies renouvelables demande plus de
métaux donc on en arrive vous énergies
renouvelables vous avez un postulat qui
est signée souvenirs sont bon de
dénoncer ce green washing
oui alors greenwashing ou peut-être un
tout petit peu trop fort parce qu'on
pourrait dire que dans les gens qui
fantasme sur effectivement le
un monde 100% énergies renouvelables
formidable où toutes les voitures
seraient seraient électriques et par
ailleurs volante un peu comme un burn
vous propose bientôt donc autonome et
volante et donc nourri aux batteries
électriques qui électricité étant
elles-mêmes produit toi ali
renouvelables donc dans ce fantasme là
je pense qu'il ya un mélange c'était il
ya des gens de qui sont juste naïf on
pourrait dire et qui voit tout ça part
d'une bonne intention et puis on a
peut-être d'autres qui sont un petit peu
plus conscients puis d'autres qui
s'intéressent au cra s'intéresse pas à
la question systémique c'est à dire
quand je fabrique un panneau solaire ou
une éolienne qu'est ce que ça implique
ou pas quelque part ailleurs et est ce
que finalement tout ça vaut le coup d'un
point de vue énergétique et
environnementale donc je suis là divers
que l'énergie vient c'est pas un peu
bullshit ah ben là c'est totalement de
bullshit malheureusement cr canal d une
énergie n'est jamais faire n'est jamais
et jamais 100% propre n'est jamais zéro
carbone ni l'énergie ni une voiture ni
quoi que ce soit et d'ailleurs même une
voiture même sans sa composante
énergétique à la cause de la question
des ressources qu'elles utilisent à
cause de ses pneus qui s'usent à cause
de son pot catalytique qui crachent
quelques mets nano grammes de platine
par kilomètre parcouru fait que dans le
périphérique parisien où la lave est
plus de platine dans le dans le bitume
en concentration que dans les mines de
russie ou l'afrique du sud on pourra pas
les exploiter parce que heureusement il
n'y a pas beaucoup donc en voiture n'est
jamais propre une énergie n'est jamais
propre ya toujours un impact il faut
accepter il ya un forcément un impact on
vient perturber ni un autre alors on
peut on pourrait égrainé les tartes à la
crème technologique sûr je sais pas
voilà on aura le temps mais du malien on
a le temps voilà mais d'une manière
générale c'est la première chose c'est
tout a toujours un impact donc moi je
suis pas forcément opposé aux énergies
renouvelables déjà il ya différents
types d'énergies renouvelables il y en a
qui sont plus ou moins consommatrices de
ressources y en a qui sont plus ou moins
impactante pour l'environnement c'est
pas forcément facile à arbitrer
d'ailleurs parce que entre chez pas quoi
l'éolienne qui tuent des chauves-souris
et et le barrage qui crée du méthane et
que sais-je encore mais ce qui ce à quoi
je me pose c'est de de croire ou de
faire croire que on va réussir à
maintenir notre niveau de dépenses pour
pas dire de gabegie énergétique et de
matières premières tout train de vie
donc quelque part notre train de vie en
tout cas notre manière de vivre qu'on va
réussir à maintenir tout ça en réglant
l'équation du carbone en rajoutant à la
limite la question nucléaire on pourrait
mettre mais qui est marginale mais tant
qu'à faire en et je suis un peu écolos
français je suis en plus contre le
nucléaire est en règle entourant juste
en déployant un monde pourrait dire à la
jeremy rifkin avec voilà un mix
énergétique qui serait basé avant tout
sur un système d'énergie renouvelable
mix d'énergie renouvelable dans lequel
on trouverait alors des éoliennes de
l'énergie houlomotrice des hydroliennes
que sais-je des panneaux solaires de
l'est du solaire thermique à
concentration fatou le mix quand on peut
imaginer on peut faire plein d'études
superbe sur tableaux excel savais pas ça
qui manque un décès des scénarios de
déploiement des énergies au niveau
mondial au niveau français au niveau
européen fin tout existe et
malheureusement tout ça se heurtent où
se heurtera à la question des ressources
parce qu on est toujours rattrapé soit
par une question de consommation
surfacique soit par une question de
consommation de telle ou telle ressource
alors on peut toujours trouver
évidemment ici et là on va essayer de
toi je sais pas il y avait eu là il y
avait une polémique à quelques années
sur la question des terres rares dans
les éoliennes arrêté rare dans les
éoliennes c'est la question du néodyme
néodyme dopé aux dysprosium
à quoi ça sert en gros ça sert à faire
les aimants permanents dont pour faire
de faire simple pour produire
d'électricité vous faites tourner un
aimant dans des bobines ou le contraire
voilà et comme il fallait réduire la
taille des éoliennes de forte puissance
a on peut vous aurez pu installer des
éoliennes onshore parce que c'est
insupportable personne n'en veut donc il
faut aller offshore est ce que vous les
avez offshore ça coûte cher d'aller
visiter chaque matin là maintenant c'est
plus compliqué d'aller en bateau quand
camionnette dont faut faire des mâts de
plus en plus gigantesque faut remonter à
5 6 8 10 12 mégawatts et si vous voulez
faire des gros magie gantès qu'avec des
gros trucs en eau comme vous avez
vraiment s étaient en vie et c'est un
peu d'économiser ce que ça va vous
coûter comment l'accroché vous essayez
de faire en sorte que ce qui est enrôlé
plus
compact possible et c'est là qu'on
trouve le néodyme parce qu'en fait ça
permet de faire des aimants qui sont une
cour une force magnétique enfin très
très très compact et c'est pour ça qu'on
trouve air du néodyme un peu partout
dans les moteurs de vos rétroviseurs
enfin partout il ya un petit moteur ou
un petit alternateur vous allez trouver
surtout si c'est miniaturisés vous avez
trouvé ces trucs là donc c'est ça la
question c'est de dire est ce que je
peux faire un monde 100 % renouvelable
de manière durable de manière soutenable
sur le moyen terme en paille de moyen
terme stoner alors on peut gloser sur la
question de est ce que là je peux faire
un effort de déploiement gigantesque les
trente prochaines années pour dire ah là
je vais réussir mais mes émissions de
co2 par quatre ont peut-être pourquoi
pas à réfléchir ça dépend si tout le
monde le fait ou pas ça dépend des
impacts géopolitique ça dépend des prix
on voit là il ya plein de choses qui
vont qui vont être bizarre parce que je
peux peut-être pu mettre tout seul mais
si je suis pas tout seul alors peut-être
comment on partage le lithium et erard
le cobalt ou autre chose mais la fois
d'après comment je fais puisque trente
ans plus tard tout ça tombe en loques
jeu peut recycler pour partie pas tous
évidemment parce que tout n'est pas
recyclé dans un panneau solaire tous les
partis clament dans une danse une
éolienne et puis dès qu'on va tomber sur
tous ces petits équipements un peu
bizarre parce que évidemment le courant
une fois que je les capter la falloir
récupérer le redresser le stocker le
distribuer les smart grids les grilles
intelligentes qui vont équilibrer
l'offre qui va donc
j'ai comme ça parce que ces
intermittents et la demande qui est le
bouge parce que de temps en temps j'aime
le chauffage et les plaques électriques
en rentrant le soir et de temps en temps
pas bien malheureusement trente ans plus
tard je suis là et puis j'ai consommé à
peu près tout ce que j'avais à consommer
en ressources minières de tel ou tel
type et font que je recommence et puis
trente ans plus tard il faut que je
recommence et trente ans plus tard il
faut que je recommence et au bout de
combien dans sa chambre peu denses
carrière qui le démographe chikhi la
croissance des marchés financiers qui
est tout ça voilà alors moi je ne suis
pas le plus ultra des catastrophistes
sur la question de sur cette question
des ressources r je pense pas forcément
que les ressources soient déclencheur
d'un effondrement d'une crise et c'est
parce qu'il ya tellement d'autres choses
que vous citez effectivement qui peuvent
être effectivement venir des marchés
financiers ou autres fin de
l'instabilité de la complexité du monde
au sens large de l'instabilité
des marchés financiers et réclame un
roulement ah oui
on s'est compris voilà non mais bien sûr
à partir du moment où enfin il faut que
la dette croise parce que voilà il faut
mais la dette n'est qu'un droit de
tirage sur le futur fait ça qui m'avait
fait dire qu'on ne démantèlera jamais
des centrales nucléaires jamais quel que
soit le montant provisionné il ya un
débat sur lequel mon quel est le montant
en euros qu'il faut provisionner qu edf
doit provisionner déconstruire pour
déconstruire pour démanteler exactement
alors des faits des chiffres la cour du
compte on avait d'autres les benchmark
et quelques tentatives qu'on a fait
retrouvez 6 milliards par les lecteurs
oui alors de f1 en dessous fractions à
200 millions aujourd'hui de 300 millions
mais ça s'inspire ce qu'ils ont ce
qu'ils ont provisionné approvisionné à
ce que la loi nous essayons du coup
voilà la réalité sur la plus tôt à
quelques milliards par par réacteur mais
finalement personne n'en sait trop rien
puisqu'on en a pas fait un seul en
entier en bout en bout et en connaissant
pas là la technologie qui sera
nécessaire alors sur ce débat là en fait
la question de dire j'ai mis trois même
si j'ai mis 3 milliards même si j'ai mis
10 milliards sur un compte en banque
c'est quoi un compte en banque en basset
quelques électrons qui se baladent sur
un disque dur donc le jour où je veux
réellement convertir mes 10 milliards en
objet sonnants et trébuchants et en
salaire réel quelle riche en calories en
robot en voilà parce qu'il va falloir
envoyer des trucs des machins radioactif
il faut démontrer que c'est un tout
c'est très compliqué le jour où je veux
convertir mais quelques électrons qui me
disent 10 milliards mais bitcoins quoi
en faire en vrais trucs qui vont servir
à démonter à ce jour là peut-être en
aura plus la disponibilité réelle
énergétique et ou de ressources pour
effectivement se permettre ça et comme
il faut laisser refroidir un peu la
casserole qui a du mal à s'arrêter quand
même tout seul donc il faut arrêter il
faut laisser refroidir peut-être chez
pas 50 cent temps avant de commencer à
s'exciter bon ben voilà dans 50 ou 100
notre capacité dans la robotique et je
sais pas quoi et la mécanisation en zone
hautement radioactive je ne présume pas
de ce qu'elle sera mais je pense
d'ailleurs il ya eu une annonce récente
c'était il ya quelques il ya un ou deux
ans d'edf qui avait commencé à dire oui
mais de façon on va pas démarrer les
démantèlements à taux zéro + 25 ans et
puis ce qui est exactement le chiffre
ils ont ils avaient déjà commencé à
décaler en disant c'était plus prudent
de toute manière de laisser refroidir un
peu plus donc voilà tranquillement
france mais sous peu ça sera les zones
tabou du futur pôle micro
comme ça voilà on déboule fait pas assez
le direct
et revenons à nos moutons c'est bon pour
vous le son c'est bon et
désolé ça j'ai perdu mon fils c'est vrai
c'est pas graphiste centrales nucléaires
ah oui non et je voulais pas forcément
lancé sur ça parce que c'est tellement à
l'échelle du rcc très et
donc vous n'êtes pas catastrophique vous
ne pensez pas que le pic ou le plateau
d'exploitation des métaux entraînerait
la primauté d'un défaut je pense pas que
ce soit un déclencheur bon ça peut être
ça peut être un facteur aggravant
ça peut être effectivement des choses
qui font que quand on se retourne en et
asus ah oui il ya ça aussi donc c'est
ça viendra oui effectivement rendre plus
difficile peut-être une manière de
stabiliser ou devrait agir effectivement
en fonction du nombre qu'on sera tout ça
est aussi évidemment un paramètre qui
qui complexifie on parle l'équation mais
je j'ai du mal à croire qu'effectivement
ça soit un élément déclencheur je vais
vous envoyer votre ingénieur du son
pourrait vous remettre cliquable korian
maintenant c'est parce qu'il y en a
combien de temps faut jouer avec
l'équipe mais j'ai pas de câble si
je sors un peu comme cela
ouais mais bon on verra bien bon voilà
on est très à cheval sur la qualité se
tenait absolument et
on revient sur les low tech
pourquoi les low tech est ce que c'est
les los teques façon madagascar c'est à
dire qu'à madagascar comme ils ont pas
grand chose ils apprennent à tout
recycler un maximum pour ça dure le plus
longtemps est-ce que c'est des lots tels
que façon madagascar ou cuba
alors les low tech il ya effectivement
voilà c'est un mot qui veut tout dire et
rien dire on peut il ya plein de autant
de définitions que personne qui en use -
les los teques mais notez qu'à moi au
départ c'est juste pour dire attention
aux high tech c'est à dire tout ce
qu'ils plus on va on va être plus on va
enrichir technologiquement plus on va
vivre à accélérer le phénomène que je
décrivais tout à l'heure à savoir usage
dispersif parce que quelques nanogrammes
dans chaque téléphone ça sera perdue les
objets connectés demain sauf les
connecter 50 faire des métaux partout
et plus je vais complexifier le
recyclage quand on n'a pas trop parlé
mais voilà un recyclage d'un smartphone
c'est un truc un peu compliqué site
ortec sa rejoigne pas le ghana où
l'afrique de l'ouest ou le pakistan ou
la chine même si ça rejoint la poignée
du zig mondiale qui est capable de
traiter ce genre de produits
électroniques qui récupère au mieux une
quinzaine de métaux encore pas 100% sur
la cinquantaine que contient le
smartphone donc de toute manière c'est
un carnage ou s'il écologique nous
aurons encore sarah dirren oui là pour
ce qui est du recyclage informel oui
certaines danger parce que c'est
du recyclage et enfin voila moi j'étais
sur le recyclage fort mais c'est à dire
celui qu'on va réaliser avec les
meilleures normes environnementales qui
les y fleurit voilà celui qu'on voit
celui en bouleau briquet pour vérifier
quels types de plastiques sait et on va
récupérer grosso modo lors du
microprocesseur et quelques autres trucs
c'est effectivement un petit peu moins
bien donc il ya des belles images qui
circulent sur blessure bouilhou sur un
an innovation au nigeria au ghana etc
donc ça iéna c'est moi qui ai perdu le
fil je veux continuer ses high et low
tech voilà donc moi ces attentions high
tech parce que ça nous envoie dans le
mur en tout cas la solution peut pas
être juste une sortie par le haut
technologiques à venir j'ai tout les
techno disponible qui vont me permettre
de franchir le mur climatique relation
si la technologie va pas nous sauver
voilà donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait du coup
et d'où ce mot un peu low-tech alors
léautey qu'on peut dire yahia il ya une
genèse on pourrait aller chercher chez
eux et un esprit des schumacher pendant
les 70 il y avait la question d appeler
ça lui les intermediate technology en
français ça avait été traduit par les
technologies appropriées il ya eu tout
un mouvement comme ça à la fin des
années 60 début 70
qui était un peu poste décolonisation et
transferts de technologie aide au
développement donc on avait commencé à
monter dans l'année 50 60 des usines
clés en main dans des pays ex colonie et
puis ça finit par tomber en décrépitude
aile gauche à droite parce que c'était
un peu difficile à maintenir tout ça et
donc il ya eu un mouvement et notamment
schumacher avec les boucles ce succès
mondial sa place - les beautiful
qui voit là lui prônait en fait des
technologies un peu moins complexe à
dire t'es pas le roi et de gandhi non
plus mais c'était pas la super usine
high tech de l'époque avec de
l'automation un vrai bon jour puisque
avait déjà des choses avec de
l'électronique etc et c'était plutôt le
truc entre les deux des bonnes machines
outils des trucs au point envoyé canton
dont ils pourraient servir un peu mieux
puis au lieu d'aller claquer 200
millions je sais pas quoi de l'époque eh
bien peut-être c'était une manière de
dépenser l'argent de manière un peu plus
durable et de réellement faire du
transfèrement ça a eu ça a eu un succès
d'estimé je pense que ça a vraiment été
suivre ce que c'était d'un point de vue
business c'est moins intéressant pour
les grandes entreprises qui pouvaient
faire ce transfert technologique est
monté ces sujets une clé en main voilà
donc donc ça c'est un peu le côté on
pourrait dire le ca a donné le
ca a donné peut-être une partie des los
teques de madagascar où aujourd'hui où
il ya tout un mouvement à l'hôtel je
pense pas aux low tech lab de corentin
de chatelperron que je crois ce 30 ans
très sympathique ou les poussées partie
en tout cas il est parti de la question
de dire comment les pays du sud peuvent
répondre à des besoins un peu
fondamentaux on dirait eau potable
réfrigération et c est donc il a il a
monté quelque chose comme ça pour
collecter des des technologies de
débrouille mais maintenant c'est en
train de prendre un peu de l'ampleur et
il se dit et comment ça je peux m'en
inspirer pour aussi faire des choses
quelque part dans les pays développés
gaspilleurs - mais l'hôte est qu'elles
sont plus bien s'ils figurent ou en
récession économique d'aspect y en aura
c'est sûr que nico on pourra revenir en
tension infections sur ce sujet là alors
moi mais l'hôte est qu'elles sont plus
elles sont plus grognons elles sont plus
énervés elles viennent elles partent
d'une opposition au high tech elles sont
pas au départ sur la question de dire
comment je vais
je sais pas aider les gens au nigeria
avoir de l'eau potable ou je sais pas
quoi de l'assainissement etc de manière
simple et pas cher et efficace
moi ça part plutôt de dire mais
finalement ici comment on va faire
atterrir savez social ce vaisseau
spatial un peu incroyable qui est quand
même sur un taux de de consommation et
de gâchis de ressources qui est
effectivement pas soutenable à moyen
terme et donc
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire par rapport à
par rapport à cette contrainte l'arrêt
puis on pourrait dire il ya d'autres
dans l'univers connexes des los teques
ans pour r il ya pas mal de questions
autour de l'innovation frugal et ça
c'est plutôt les los teques version
entreprise on pourrait dire où c'est la
logan on va dire c'est voilà la voiture
renault qui est un peu dépouillés lé pas
enrichi de plein de trucs donc elle est
moins chère et elle permet d'adresser
peut-être un espèce de marché émergent
de classe moyenne des nouveaux
des pays où certains blogs ouvrent ce
permis aux pauvres sans colère de peur
d'avoir un acte d'achat que tout le
monde alors que ça c'est plutôt la
version business des low tech qui m'ont
- 21 secondes - parce que voilà j'en vis
pas et je fais pas du conseil en low
tech donc
voila mais c'est plutôt ça et donc les
low tech alors que ça veut dire
hypothèque donc il n'ya pas de label en
low tech i à pass à celle au texas est à
noter que ce serait affreusement
compliquée parce que c'est et il n'y a
pas de la définition serait serait
impossible tron on parle je sais pas un
vélo un vélo c'est on pourrait dire c1
c2 tech parce que c'est assez durable à
vélo enfin quand tu joues un pull alors
ça c'est le coup d'après voilà j'avais
venir et mais par contre pour faire un
fabrique un vélo c'est juste
affreusement compliquée d'accord
imaginez de prendre un forgeron du
village enfin s'il sentait que ça
existait encore et de lui faire
fabriquer un dérailleur ça serait quand
même difficile or il ya des vélos sans
ferrailleurs sans dérailleur mais bon il
faut fabriquer la chaîne excellent c'est
très compliqué mais finalement c'est un
objet assez simple ylvanie michelin les
70 saurait dire convivial donc un truc
qu'on peut s'approprier qu'on peut
réparer facilement et c'est alors
low-tech du coup pour moi c'est plutôt
une démarche c'est plutôt une démarche
pour s'établir à attention donc la
sortie par les eaux technologique bon
peut-être enfin si on si on pouvait
éviter de mettre tous nos oeufs dans le
même panier on est dans la voiture de
james dean on fonce vers la falaise mais
promis voilà il ya des milliers des
millions que dis-je de chercheurs
d'ingénieurs et de techniciens en blouse
blanche qui effectivement sont en train
de vous préparer les ailes on les a pas
encore vu mais promis juré elles vont
sortir au lieu de faire ça voilà une
démarche en aidant mon comment on fait
atterrir le truc donc moi j'aime bien
résumé ça en trois questions finalement
c'est pourquoi je produis qu'est ce que
je produis et comanche produit alors
pourquoi je produis mais c'est la
question de la sobriété c'est à dire
finalement bah oui puisque rien n'est
propre aucune énergie aucun voilà il n'y
a rien qui ait zéro carbone neutre et
c'est la première chose peut-être c'est
à dire est-ce que je peux me passer de
certaines choses est ce que je peux
faire de la sobriété et c'est à dire
faire dont j'ai appelé sa sobriété ou
austérité bas on peut appeler ça qu'on
veut enfin sobriété austérité frugalité
ça peut être contraints ou volontaires
ça peut être par la voix ne peuvent être
contraints ou volontaires
pour moi ça sera ça sera un mix c'est à
dire que je pense qu'il ya un aspect
réglementaire par exemple on pourrait
dire faire 80 km heure plus tôt 90 km
sur la route
l'argument en tout cas de la sobriété à
côté de l'argument de la sécurité du
nombre de morts sur les routes a été
employée et on va consommer moins
d'essence d'avoir c'est super du coup en
plus vous montez jour je vous montre un
petit peu la taxe donc ça voilà ça ça
peut être réglementaire et ça peut être
aussi volontaire c'est à dire qu'il ya
des ya plein de mouvements par exemple
ce n'est pas autour du zéro déchets
autour des magasins en vrac autour des
recycleries ressourcerie il se passe
plein de choses comme ça dans les
territoires où c'est des citoyens des
collectifs les jeux c'est pas les amap
l'on peut dire c'est l'eau tex et des
circuits courts les riber café un dessin
marché à grande échelle non non j'ai pas
dit que ça fait c'est forcément un gros
chêne enfin moi j'ai un compte qu'est ce
qu'on dit grande échelle c'est quoi
alors là c'est on a sauté je ferais
pareil trois questions alors finalement
vers
midi si c'est quoi c'est quoi une
grande échelle pour vous c'est l'échelle
de tours c'est celle de lyon c'est
l'échelle de paris cg c'est long et
c'est une excellente question qui est au
coeur de l'action moi j'ai un côté un
peu un peu jacobins alors c'est mon
défaut un peu un peu français je sais
que par rapport au hacking est tout bon
choix je marche sur des oeufs en fait
donc l'échelle idéalement c'est
l'échelle de la planète évidemment donc
si j'étais logique j'en appelle à une
organisation mondiale de l'environnement
j'en appelle à une taxe carbone mondiale
j'en appelle à la coop 21 22 23 24 25 et
puis malheureusement avec le résultat
qu'on sait c'est que bon c'est très
difficile d'un point de vue diplomatique
et pour le différentes façons et
américains négocient la donc mais même
au niveau de l'europe on pourrait dire à
27 ou 28 ou 26 ça dépend combien ça
dépend si on rajoute je ne sais pas la
catalogne l'écossé la corse comme des
trucs indépendants ou pas bon
c'est difficile on n'a pas la même
histoire avec je ne sais pas la pologne
on n'a pas la même aujourd'hui la même
les mêmes industries on n'a pas les
mêmes rapport à tout ça donc cesser de
tout moyen extrêmement complexe de se
mettre d'accord quand on est si nombreux
malgré tout il faut pas abandonner ce
multilatéralisme mais il ya quand même
peu de chances malheureusement le sais
c'est pas un pari très très compliqué
sur sur l'histoire que ça est assez vite
que le mouvement est assez vite quelle
que soit la solution surtout si en plus
on se concentre uniquement sur la
question justement des énergies vertes
qui finalement je vois je j'aimais
j'aimais à gauche pour faire semblant
d'émettre un peu moins mettre un peu
moins à droite alors après il ya quelle
échelle y aller chez le personnel
familial un oncle à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure il ya des gens bas il se
met à faire du compostage à lombrics
dans leur jardin ou même sur leur balcon
dans paris ya des gens qui décident de
prendre leur douche froide il y en a
d'autres qui prennent plus l'avion je
sais pas il a d'autres qui vont
enfourché leur vélo plutôt calé en
voiture qui pensent que le viol ou qui
réduisent la quantité de vin parce qu'on
n'est pas obligé non plus d'être
extrêmement fins de vertières manger
trois fois quatre fois de la viande par
semaine c'est déjà
fabuleux par rapport à ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui obligés de manger de la
viande extrêmement non plus c'est
pourquoi ces extrêmes de haddon plus
manger de viande non parce que ça ça ça
engendre en fait c'est parce que plus à
rejoindre une complexité voilà une
organisation qui est quand même plus
plus grand en tout cas adapte c'est à
dire que une fois que tout le monde fait
ça et puis que dans chaque restaurant
tout et vegan et c'est super tous les
menus etc tout va bien mais tant qu'il y
en a très peu bon bah je vais me
souvenir si la masse inertielle voilà
c'est un peu comme les couches lavables
c'est vous pouvez faire des couches
lavables mais si vous êtes tout seul à
faire des couches lavables c'est plus
dur que vous si tout le monde fait les
couches lavables et qu'il y avait un
service de ramassage et le nettoyage des
couches par exemple donc il ya des
aspects un peu de masse critique au
ciment alors ctsp un peu personnel et
familial je pense qu'il est nécessaire
intéressant et voilà il ya des gens qui
s'inscrivent là dedans je sais pas la
décroissance etc
mais à un moment ça a ses limites quoi
et pour paraphraser bordure pourrait
dire que les courses sont un sport de
combat quoi c'est à dire que pour
essayer de voile à aller faire ses
courses sans générer de déchets sans
être dans l'agriculture c'est pas juste
pour prendre la nourriture évitez
l'huile de palme dans tous les produits
transformés enfin voilà tout ça ça prend
du temps de la connaissance il faut lire
les étiquettes en tout petit et ça à
multiplier partout enfin voilà près
votre ordinateur vous voyez une question
d'atteinte qui peut rebondir sur ce que
vous me dites quels sont les lobbys qui
pourrait influencer pour réorganiser la
production industrielle vers des
produits plus simples faciles à réparer
quelles sont les entreprises qui vont
accepter mon premier d'abandonner de
l'obsolescence programmée
alors ça c'est mes vingt questions à
tiroirs parce que l'obsolescence est
elle programmée fin qu'est ce qu'on
appelle l'obsolescence programmée simple
la cartouche de jean teulère documente
les fringues la fast fashion
voilà un au cou donc on est d'accord
qu'il ya déjà 2 il ya du programme est
techniquement éventuellement on verra
music hall il ya eu il ya du programme
et
il ya du programme et au niveau
marketing quoi pourquoi est ce que je
vais faire là je vais faire la queue à
la sortie du nouvel iphone alors que
celui que j'ai marche bien même si j'ai
compris qu'il réduisait un petit peu sa
vitesse quand même sur le voilà donc ça
ok mais après il ya d'autres il
yad'autres ya d'autres il yad'autres
obsolescence qui sont des autres
connaissances qu'ils sont et ce qu'elles
sont voulus pas voulu vous avez en
savoir plus que moi là dessus ce n'est
pas l'absence systémique par votre
software et hardware aujourd'hui vous
avez des ordinateurs qui pourrait encore
très bien marché mais un moment la suite
d'antivirus et compagnie fin finit par
plus être supporté voilà alors à moins
de passer effectivement sur les
logiciels libres etc il ya des
techniques pour un film passe de windows
linux chez l'un on est tranquille tout
voilà exactement je voulais pas citer
linux mais c'est bien on peut faire de
la pub ici à première vue clinique tout
à fait donc voila et puis après il ya
sans doute des obsolescences à
techniques réelles mais c'est plus
difficile à qualifier alors est ce qu'il
ya des entreprises en gros si je
comprends bien la question qui ont
intérêt à aller vers un monde avec des
objets plus durable etc la réponse est
sans doute oui un peu alors je sais pas
déjà des entreprises chez bateau ce qui
travaille sur la rénovation du bâtiment
voilà ça c'est des choses qui ont peu là
on peut faire de la sobriété parce que
si on a un bâtiment bien rénové bien
pensé bien conçu ce pas quoi bon des
gens peu dé travailler dans la
réparation était armé d'une en grande
majorité j'ai peur que les autres pour
les entreprises ça sera quand même
difficile parce que hockey n'ont pas été
désignés pour ça voilà il ya des en fait
mais c'est surtout faut survivre en
terme allant un iphone une entreprise
c'est mieux ça dépend ce qu'on appelle
entreprises c'est toujours je pense est
difficile de comparer le boulanger du
coin qui est une entreprise et c'est
bien la concurrence et tout et puis
plonger du coup maintenant ils font même
plus leur pain y voit là oui alors c'est
tout d'abord lorsqu'on actuel de bourget
quoi effectivement un coût devrait
boulou gemini web on allait il ne reste
que quelques uns mais bon il faut
effectivement on les trouvait alors
souvent les voilà on va dire une
entreprise un peu standard 1 elle a
besoin de se développer afin de
développer ce rocher d'affaires parce
que elle est endettée et derrière la
dette etc donc il ya déjà tout
c'est rare qu'on retrouve les
entreprises qui acceptent de faire
acquérir en disant tiens moi l'année
prochaine je vais divisé mon chiffre
d'affaires par deux parce que c'est
génial et c'est bon pour la planète en
général ce qu'on trouve c'est là qu'on
se trouve à la limite entre l'oeuvre et
la réalité la bonne foi ou le
greenwashing ces entreprises qui
arrivent à se développer et pourtant au
détriment d'autres mais on se dit une
fois qu'on aura fait ça partout on va on
voit pas très bien comment ça se passera
donc il ya des gens qui travaillent
condé super idée il ya bien un designer
en ingénierie travail sur machine à la
vie s'appelle l'increvable durée de vie
50 ans avec une [__] non car ça c'est
la version encore plus non non celles là
n est électrique et tout mais voilà elle
contient pas beaucoup d'électronique
elle est modulaire réparé à manon
qu'elle n'a pas le n a pas le programme
numéro 8 avec essorage qui tombe en rade
au bout de quatre ans et puis mon bon
monsieur ce serait plus compliqué de
l'ouvrir que d'en acheter une neuve
voilà donc l est l increvable est ce
qu'une entreprise pourra s'emparer de ça
et dire un moment oui je vais vendre des
increvables à tout le monde pour une
fois et demi le prix d'une machine
normal peut-être mais ça sort avant
cannibalisant du business existant je ne
pense pas que le lobby des machines
elles des fabricants de d'électroménager
puisse dire c'est super je vais rentrer
là dedans donc non j'ai peur qu
effectivement malheureusement les forces
vives de la nation soit pas forcément
les corps intermédiaires soit six
branches et que sa sueur sur la question
de la sobriété ou de l'éco conception
parce que c'est ça la question derrière
de dire je fais des choses modulaire
réparable et c'est quand on est dans du
marginal on peut avoir des formidables
aventures industrielles et commerciales
je dois faire phone par exemple on
pourrait dire faire feu ne s'est pas
parfait loin de là je ne fais pas plus
pour faire fun j'en ai pas je suis resté
avec un bon vieux nokia donc je vais pas
d'écran tactile et tout ça mais ferme
pas de théo 10 un vrai 32 10 je sais pas
j'ai pas comment ça s'appelle un
revenu ou trois questions vous avez
waikiki tout à l'heure où je vous ai
coupé alors donc et la sobriété donc les
ai donc la sobriété sa pose
effectivement la question c'est quoi la
sobriété la boîte 2 ouvre la boîte de
pandore et je peux tout faire du plus
liberticides au plus sympathique
évidemment donc on peut parler
d'austérité et c'était un bon train moi
ce que je pense c'est que la société
déjà liberticide
vous avez remarqué simplement comme ça
je sais pas je suis tombé dessus un jour
voilà nommé liberticides au sens allez
on va être sympa au sens xviiie siècle
du terme c'est à dire la liberté des uns
s'arrête là où commence celle des autres
et donc pour vivre en société pour faire
société il faut bien que je me fixe
quelques règles et donc ces règles
quelque part s'oppose à ma liberté donc
prenons un exemple je sais pas j'ai pas
droit de rouler avec un char d'assaut
sur une route française sam est
interdite même si j'ai les moyens de me
payer un char d'assaut
d'occasions c'est pas possible parce que
voilà il est pas immatriculé comme il
faut il fait plus de trois tonnes 5 donc
façon j'ai pas le permis etc c'est donc
liberticide on pourrait faire mais bon
après vous imaginez un semblant de
charlas souffle cdcf bien sûr mais on
pourrait dire des chars d'assaut même si
on a le même si on a juste vider le
canon et on voit la santé au but mais on
ne le fait pas et c'est quelque part on
pourrait en exagérant dire c'est
liberticide d'accord bon ça veut dire
qu'en gros la puissance publique à un
moment elle a dit ce qu'ils roulent sur
les routes c'est il ya un certain poids
des voitures aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire on essaye de prendre des
voitures qui sont devenus de plus en
plus lourdes au fur et à mesure des
décennies parce qu'elles sont de plus en
plus équipés parce qu'elles sont plus en
plus confortable parce qu'elles sont
plus en plus sur bien et on essaie de
faire en sorte qu'elles émettent de
moins en moins pour faire son sommes de
moins en moins quelques voilà qu'elles
concernent des droits qu'elles émettent
de moins en moins de co2 par du malheur
dinars d'ide on a eu cette discussion
avec jacques blamont nord pointe souvent
j'ai bien manquer fondateur du prince
spatial français qui a envoyé des
ballons sur vénus qui a cru le pas de
tir de kourou un
pratiquement avec ses petites mains qui
travaillent toujours au cnes on a on a
eu cette discussion de la voiture légère
qui consomment pas beaucoup qui se
démocratise 1 la voiture à un litre
voilà c'est génial c'est que tout le
monde va en prendre les faits relevant à
cet effet d'après ouais alors où
l'enfance de cet effet robot a bien sûr
falloir en parler parce que c'est c'est
dans les promesses technologique c'est
un des problèmes principaux c'est un des
principaux c'est à dire que prenons
l'exemple de l'impact environnemental
d'internet d'accord donc le numérique
c'est un bon endroit où on fait des
progrès extrêmement rapide et si peu que
s'ils tentaient
exponentielle éventuellement donc il ya
tout le débat autour parme de la
consommation énergétique des datacenters
c'est très à la mode vont très bien bon
les data center on n'arrête pas
d'améliorer le truc c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui par par octet stocker ou
outre été procès c'est la consommation
énergétique est bien plus faible que ce
que c'était il ya cinq ans il ya dix ans
aucun problème
sauf que maintenant on est passé de la
cenc une faute ou un 1h30 de vidéos
exactement
aujourd'hui or si je prends juste la
partie stockage c'est donc huit états
octets que ces musées ça mieux - donc
huit mille milliards de gigaoctets donc
chaque internaute on pourrait dire si on
a quatre milliards je sais pas chaque
internaute à 2000 giga octet stockées
sur le cloud vont très bien on en attend
20 donc de passer de 8 à 20 d'ici deux
trois ans maximum
effectivement basse et et les vidéos et
un effet sur le support vidéo est en
train de parts de sortir de la
civilisation de l'écrit de ressortir
d'acier sur l'écrit pour rentrer à
nourrir une sorte de civilisation orale
cette fois elle sera sera vidéo ça c'est
pas la situation orale des griots qui
était capable de d'apprendre au maire
parker sas et c'est plutôt la
civilisation orale des grouillots qui
regardent des tutos voilà donc cet effet
rebond il existe il existe en numérique
il mais il existe effectivement des
transports l'autopartage c'est un bon
exemple j'aime bien de prendre bombe à
l'autopartage a priori je mets trois
personnes j'ai une voiture au lieu d'une
seule enfin ou de trois voitures qui se
bat l'âme c'est forcément un effet
massif majeurs sauf que dans la voiture
et un étudiant qui fait paris strasbourg
pour aller voir un copain ou une copine
pour boire une bière parce que c'est pas
cher il y en a un autre il aurait pris
le train mais puis il le prend pas parce
que c'est trop cher et que finalement il
a c'est plus souple et puis vint opus
est déposée pas loin de chez lui et puis
le conducteur à lui il fait peut-être
même paris strasbourg plus souvent parce
qu'il a la contribution économique des
deux autres pour payer l'essence et il a
plus de sous pour ses freins effacement
donc du coup les à la fin de la journée
comme si nos amis anglo-saxons makelele
fait quel est l'effet réel de
l'autopartage on n'en sait trop rien est
effectivement mais le peu d'études eu un
peu échantillonnée et quelques
échantillons sociologique qu'on peut
qu'on peut récupérer au tour d
des études de comportement montre
qu'effectivement il ya un effet rebond
mais alors de combien et est-ce qu'à la
fin c'est bon pas bon donc c'est alors
sur la voiture on pourrait dire oui
sûrement sur la voiture légère bien sûr
qu'il faut tout se passait au vélo est
là le vélo l'effet rebond sur le vélo ça
va être un peu plus difficile parce que
même s'il ya une foultitude d'innovation
sur le vélo c'est génial les vélos
couchés les vélos pour déménager les
vélos pour transporter les enfants enfin
c'est chouette très bien mais bon après
défaire au bon vélo ça sera quand même
une limite non sauf que l'on peut pas
dire à tout le monde demain matin quand
on va passer au vélo parce que la
civilisation elle a été haut construite
autour de la delà de la com mobilité
motorisée donc il faut passer
progressivement à quelque chose d'autre
que mon fils pour combattre cette
inertie enfin c'est la réalité des
menaces qui nous entoure
bah
c'est là que moi j'ai un peu mes limites
parce que je suis juste un mot des
s'ingénièrent je suis pas un psychologue
sociologues politologues anthropologue
que sais-je mais je pense qu'il ya ya ya
ya justement c'est là que je pense qu'il
faut un mélange de 2 2 pouces et
culturelle de
d'expérimentation locales
de donner envie d'avoir envie comme
disait quelqu'un qui m'a pas passer à
fin de l'année donc et robert un
accompagnement ouais et en
accompagnement
réglementaire
normatif
d'exemplarité aussi que bon ben si je
rentre du japon avec
qu'un avion avec un avion privé bon
c'est sûr que ça donne pas envie pour
les verts de paris et convoqués temps de
pagnol voilà donc c'est un est il que
c'est faux bon voila moi je ne me
prononcerai pas voilà donc on voit bien
que la cc c'est un peu compliqué c'est à
dire que moi je pense que fin de
l'histoire a montré que les gens
pouvaient se serrer la ceinture pas
forcément circonstances très agréable
j'entends bien j'ai pas du tout envie
car rien n'a rien combien jour deux
sujets c'est à dire se serrer la
ceinture voilà mais on serre la ceinture
c'est mieux quand tout le monde se serre
la ceinture ce faire c'est à la gabegie
d'un côté et puis que moi je suis
obligée de me serrer la ceinture parce
que j'ai effectivement je sais pas quoi
des taxes qui monte des impôts comme
c'est comme ça sur les gens tant sur des
composantes énergétiques ou aux fins va
bien la taxe carbone les bonnets rouges
avec avec la taxe kilométrique sur les
transports etc donc c'est pas très
difficile de faire monter la sauce sur
ces sur les sujets comme sa bouille
rouge c'est un peu parce que les
autoroutes étaient toujours gratuite
sous les 10 du soudan
oui voilà donc ça c'est anne de bretagne
dans son contrat de mariage
effectivement bon alors les routes sont
gratuites et donc l'impact était plus
fort peut-être en bretagne que bon la
fin de l'histoire c'est que
c'est que les cochons bonnet rouge alors
9 à l'heure du marché de la gendarmerie
parce que comme il faisait aussi les
plus de la gendarmerie paraît-il qui
sont un petit peu fait un cerveau des
monts changeons de sujet
vous parler d'éducation et vous êtes
contre les écrans l'école ouais pour
finalement j'ai commis un ouvrage a été
moins bien reçu que les low tech n'est
pas l'éducation nationale c'est ça eux
notamment mais pas que par aussi toute
une cyber communauté y perdre geeks
branchés bienvenus voilà mais pas
forcément de chez vous un pape annoncé
plus tôt dans les chais les pédagogues
un peu universitaires travaillant sur
ces questions là
alors oui effectivement
alors ça paraît assez choquant parce que
voilà surtout voile à l'école nos
enfants c'est l'avenir
bon il faut que l'école s'inscrivent
dans la modernité il faut qu'elle
apprenne aux gens se servir du numérique
a pas tomber dans les panneaux
marketing ou fake news ou que sais-je
donc oui voilà donc il ya toutes ces
questions là autour de quel doit être le
rôle de l'école ou pas par rapport à ça
ont très bien mais bon moi j'ai regardé
ça un peu froidement si je puis dire en
d'abord la question de la première
question pourra dire c'est la question
pédagogique actions pédagogiques crs
qu'on apprend mieux ou est-ce qu'on
n'apprend pas mieux avec le numérique
est ce qu'on apprend mieux en passant
par l'écran ou en passant par un livre
d'autres supports
le fait est qu'en fait malgré toutes les
promesses qui sont qui se promènent d'un
rapport officiel à un autre il n'y a
rien aujourd'hui aucune étude qui prouve
qu'on apprend mieux avec le numérique au
contraire le peu de choses qu'on a c'est
l'étude un peu macro sur la base des
données pisano céder un peu vieux parce
que c'est une étude de 2015 qui sur les
données 2012 mais on n'a rien de plus
récents un niveau macro qui en fait
montre il ya aucune corrélation entre
l'effort de numérisation de l'école d'un
côté et les résultats des élèves donc
c'est random on a dans tous les sens
donc c'est pas parce que le danemark
réussit mieux à l'école et le danemark a
investi dans le numérique donc faut que
je fasse pareil non non ça s'appelle un
syllogisme et le raisonnement n'est pas
correct et puis sinon on a des petites
études plus
sur les petits échantillons et qui
essaye de montrer si par exemple on
montre une vidéo en ligne un truc sur un
livre etc et en fait on s'aperçoit qu'on
était des fois même un contenu trop
riche et
et peut être contre-productif alors
qu'est ce qu'on a essayé de dénoncer
avec mama coauteur à carignan vini
coterie ce pardon
c'est le fait qu'en fait c'était là
c'est la seule chose qui reste et a
proposé j'entends delà de la mandature
précédente quoi c'est à dire en gros le
vent le devant le bon ben voilà la
baisse du niveau de l'école surtout la
baisse de la concentration des élèves le
manque de motivation etc finalement on
allait leur apporter un support
numérique et salir les motiver il avait
bossé ensemble c'est génial et c est en
réalité c'est marrant parce qu'on est
remonté au 19e siècle avec les lanternes
magiques séquence être de powerpoint et
au 19e siècle on retrouve exactement les
mêmes phrases que dans les rapports
aujourd'hui sur les tablettes c'est ça
va être génial pour les élèves ça va les
motiver vont travailler en groupe y
allant après c'était edison en 1910 qui
a dit les livres vont disparaître tout
va devenir cinématographique d'après
finalement ces livres ont pas disparu on
est passé à la radio puis après la
télévision puis dans les 60 kg avait un
truc ça s'appelait les machines à
enseigner c'est skinner qui faisait ça
cette espèce de dispositifs
électromécaniques où on répondait à des
sortes de qcm puis après arrivée
l'informatique et c est en fait à chaque
fois les promesses technologiques ont
fait pschitt parce que pour apprendre
c'est pas le sait pas c'est pas ce à
quoi on s'attrape vers quoi on pas ce
qui compte c'est la relation faite entre
l'enseignant et les enseignants et le
fait qu'on a envie d'apprendre on a tous
été je pense notre jeunesse soit sauvé
par un prof qu'on aimait bien dans une
matière on n'était pas très bon soit au
contraire dégoûté par un prof qui était
pas bon dans une autre matière c'est ça
le concept est donc le numérique maman
n'y changent rien et on fait par rapport
à annoncer un peu long mais toutes ces
questions de toutes ces questions de
motivation toutes ces questions de
de l'effort voilà c'est en fait tout est
vérifié par exemple quand on dans
l'école numérique tout doit devenir un
jeu voilà donc c'est les serious games
est un peu cette mode l'anr aussi les
entreprises n'ont malheureusement il ya
des choses où il faut faire un effort et
d'ailleurs ça serait quoi des citoyens
qu'on aurait formé à tout apprendre sans
faire aucun effort parce que tout aurait
été ludique et sympathique je pense
malheureusement que c'est pas forcément
le rendre service et du coup ça c'est la
question disons vraiment pédagogique
alors moi je l'a jeté comme un pavé dans
la mare pour faire un peu réagir et dire
mais bon on n'ose pas possible que tout
le monde soit d'accord avec cette espèce
de consensus
affreux entre je sais pas quoi le maire
de village vieillissant qui a peur de
passer pour un vieux con
les deux profs désemparés qui feront si
oui finalement ça ou autre chose ça va
lire motivés et puis à côté les intérêts
sonnants et trébuchants des fabricants
edison hier ou des éditeurs de logiciels
aujourd'hui voilà ces lits mais
finalement c'est un non sens c'est un
choix pédagogique et rationnelle et donc
je suis pas contre le numérique juste
pour les conditions pour les questions
environnementales qu'on a mentionné tout
à l'heure je suis très content que mon
dentiste soit numérique et j'ai pas du
tout envie de revenir et mairie qu'au
sens il à l'équipement pour ça la radio
des chiens bien en belgique
voilà avant mais j'ai pas envie de
revenir au d'anti des années 70 moi non
plus alors après la question c'est
jusqu'où on pousse le confort numérique
dans le dans le dans le médical parce
qu'on pourrait glisser sur le
transhumanisme et je sais pas quoi mais
on peut y vivre ah bah voilà mais sans
aller jusque là ok si ça apporte un réel
avantage bon on peut discuter c'est
peut-être pas loin mais pourquoi pas
mais là ça n'apporte pas davantage donc
en gros on est en train de se dire qu'on
va acheter des centaines de milliers des
millions de tablettes regardons les
mêmes proches en gardant les mêmes profs
évidemment racontant tout le temps qu'on
va les former et que ça va être génial
qu'on va leur apporter des supports tout
mais comme d'habitude on les laissera
cul nu avec avec les roses équipements
et puis ils vont regarder ça
non pas parce qu'ils sont numériquement
analphabètes pas du tout mais parce
qu'il ya un dauphin web non mais non
juste parce que parce qu'il faut prévoir
un plan backup si le tableau numérique
marche pas parce que il le serveur parce
qu'on a tous des dizaines de code pour
rentrer dans les différents trucs et est
en fait au lieu d'avoir un sas et
l'aspect pédagogique mais sur l'aspect
maintenant on pourrait bien sûr aspects
sanitaires j'ai donc on s'est quand même
il ya quand même de plus en plus de
choses qui sortent sur la question de
l'addiction numérique notamment chez les
ados notamment donc sur les hoax elisa
do les personnes âgées avec candy crunch
c'est dramatique ah oui je fréquente un
peu ridicule ça ma mère
bon voilà en tant qu effectivement la
diction peut être sur les réseaux
sociaux peut être sur les jeux etc ça
dépend sans doute des âges et des et des
gens mais du coup
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait l'école numérique
qu'est ce qu'elle dit aux parents en
fait elle dit aux parents le numérique
c'est bien la table et c'est bien
l'ordinateur c'est bien parce que voilà
il n'ya pas parce qu'on en fait à
l'école et ce qu'on fait à l'école c'est
bien moi ce que je vais les gens sortis
fissiles c'est bien là dessus je viens
c'est bien le diplôme ning je vais
réussir je vais devenir un pro en
orthographe parce que je vais avoir un
logiciel apprenants qui va me dire
attention philippe la semaine dernière
tu avais déjà oublié un s il me semble
trop imparfait du subjonctif fait
attention voilà donc bon caisse et je
pense qu'on est on est un peu dans le
jeu au sol dans ce délire là et puis
donc on avertit pas les parents du coût
du risque tu risques numériques du fait
que les usages du numérique comme tout
le reste devrait être modérée réfléchi
et c est contrôlé à certains âges c'est
à dire pas d'écran dans sa chambre
et en plus elle incite elle oblige les
enfants à se connecter après l'école
puisque je dois aller sur le cahier de
texte numérique je dois aller faire des
recherches je dois apprendre à faire des
powerpoint ou un on va mon fils il passe
plus de temps à apprendre comment on
fait un peu léger accent dans ce qui est
maintenant il a 11 ans parce que
toujours et ben voilà comment vous voyez
le monde à moyen terme l'avènement des
los teques arrivera avant ou après
l'effondrement
alors
il est sans doute sur d'arrivée après si
effondrement il y a c'est fondamental on
fera sans doute un peu plus plus l'hôtel
qu'avant parce qu'il ya des choses qui
seront offerts ne peut être plus
compliqué il ya des choses qui réclame
une organisation
une organisation sociétale complexe
c'est d'ailleurs ça qui fait que qui
disqualifie un peu les les horribles
films ou séries un peu dystopique la
sueur je sais pas alors je ne sais pas
quand même de retrouver des noms parce
que je suis pas forcément un grand fan
mais en fait non alors c'est pas ça que
je pensais que c'est un film où il ya
une espèce d'humanité très riche qui
s'est réfugié librium voilà non pas
équilibré elysium elysium voilà alors
donc il ya des riches qui sont dans le
truc et puis en bas y aller il y avait
il ya les prolétaires pas quoi ça c'est
pas possible en fait c'est pas des
jeunes qu'elles on peut on peut pas et
riche dans un lent parce que c'est des
jeunes qu'est la médecine est trop lente
et ce en france oui mais en fait il faut
il faut qu'elle soit justement à
plusieurs vitesses et fo qui est toute
une pyramide sociale parce qu'il faut
aussi voilà je prends mon avion privé ou
un hélicoptère pour faire monaco je sais
pas quoi pour rejoindre mon idée à ça il
faut un concepteur de d'hélicoptères il
faut un gars qui fasse la maintenance et
qui change les pièces détachées et c est
donc ce gars là ça peut pas juste un
prolétaire qui crèvent la faim avec sa
famille il faut qu'ils aient un avantage
à être concepteurs d'hélicoptères et le
gac et techniciens lui aussi et ces gens
là ils ont des rêves pour leurs enfants
ils espèrent qu'ils seront galeron plus
d'argent qu'ils vivront mieux que sèche
et donc il faut pour être riche
malheureusement il faut avoir une fin
pour être riche dans un monde il permet
aux logiques il faut des pauvres il faut
toutes les chaînes intermédiaire avec
des gens qui sont moins pauvres que
d'autres et qui ont un peu la trouille
de redescendre la trouille eux mêmes ou
la trouille pour leurs enfants etc et
donc c'est un peu ce que renvoie là
c'est j'aime bien le bouquin de kembs
sur comment les riches détruisent la
planète avec 7 cette réinterprétation
cette réactualisation de de thorstein
veblen avec toute cette question de la
consommation ostentatoire des des
classes supérieures et qui ensuite oui
celle là pour le coup là on sait que ça
ruisselle pour de vrai c'est pas
forcément comme le ruissellement et
économique mais voilà les les les
tentations l'a10 hissel et je fantasme
mois sur la voiture un petit peu plus
grosse de m'envoyer un de demont de mon
voisin de pavillons où je fantasme sur
les dernières vacances aux maldives de
mon collègue de bureau et je ne fantasme
pas sur le yacht de bolloré quoi parce
que je sais que le yacht de bolloré mais
inaccessible par contre eux entre eux
ils se tirent la bourre ce réellement
sur la taille de leur yacht et donc ça
descend un vrai ça donne des flux
migratoires deux jeunes personnes qui
ont tous un téléphone portable pouvant
aller sur internet voyons ces deux
sociétés d'ultra consommation du train
transformant et ensuite ça donne des
envies c'est ça oui je pense je pense je
pense pas que juste le vin ça serait
vraiment
révolue résumé affreusement que dire que
les flux migratoires sont provoqués par
cette envie de la vision un peu de
l'american way of life coque est
accessible sur internet deux fêtes
oui 2 fait forcément maintenant tout est
visible tout le temps partout donc on
peux plus mentir sur les niveaux de vie
respectifs avaient déjà discuté avec un
migrant
directement non non mais ça fait tant
souffrir ça fait partie ça se fait sans
doute partie du truc mais il ya aussi je
pense là la contrainte la contrainte qui
est lié au fait que je sais pas quand
vous êtes
planteurs de tomates
et que vous voyez arriver la tomate
concentrée sur deux les ports africains
à un prix défiant toute concurrence qui
vous permet plus de vendre votre match
sur le marché local par exemple vous
pouvez dire lempire de l'eau rouge qui
est tout récent sur cette question la
mondialisation et qui montre comment
enfin voila c'est toute la question
aussi les pays de la paysannerie
alors qu'ils ont été chassés dans les
villes donc de l'hyper urbanisation un
rythme beaucoup trop rapide c'est donc
c'est pas juste c'est pas du tout la
tentation bien sûr qui a forcément un
phénomène de culture tentation il ya
aussi le fait d'ailleurs sans doute que
quand on est parti quand ont eu le
courage de partir je pense qu'il faudra
compter
via internet et la facilité peut-être de
communication plus grande aujourd'hui
que ça se passe bien et que c'est qu'on
est content d'être parti et que le rêve
est en train de s'accomplir même si on
est en train se passer un truc vous
savez exactement mais je dis on va
étudier les flux migratoires c'était
2007 à mayotte on s'est déplacé sur
place pour discuter avec les mahorais
les anjouanais on a été faire un tour à
la campagne ce qui s'appelle la campagne
c'est la jungle a vu d anjou rennais
planter des tomates d'ailleurs dit que
les tomates ne fonctionnait pas à
mayotte mais les anjouanais ont trouvé
des techniques et on en a discuté avec
lui et on s'est rendu compte déjà qui
fuient la misère la misère parce
qu'elles ont exporté nos envies aussi
chez eux et présenter nos comportements
prédateurs sur les métaux et les
ressources et lakamy crèvent la dalle
ils sont obligés de migrer ou par
exemple dans la corne de l'afrique ils
en ont marre de voir des supertankers ou
des super bateau de pêche raser tout ce
qu'il ya devant chez eux mais ils sont
obligés de se mettre à la piraterie pour
pour vivre départ puis après ses revenus
dans les mains de la mafia est dans les
mains des passeurs les choses comme ça
c'est bon c'est toute une économie non
mais même sans aller danser dans ces
exemples-là qui sont infections les
réels échanges et comtesses pas du tout
mais même si on parle juste de deux
classes moyennes émergentes par exemple
comment comme un drap voilà la
civilisation de la voiture l'attrait de
la voiture en inde en chine
voilà on n'a aucune crédibilité
aujourd'hui en tant que
citoyens des pays de l'osce et des avec
deux voitures par foyer aux un peu plus
longtemps pour donner des leçons il a
attendu pendant là c'est compliqué vous
vous êtes un peu nombreux donc la
voiture va faire vocale mais surtout
grand plus pour le coup on a nos grandes
sociétés multinationales qui elles sont
ravies de pouvoir élargir d'élargir
leurs marchés donc effectivement soit on
est capable à un moment ou un autre de
d'enclencher j'entends au moins
d'enclencher pour pas dire y arriver au
bout de quelques décennies devant une
opposition une transition vers une
solution on serait tous à vélo peut au
bout si on excepte quelques ambulances
et je sais pas quoi et puis les
véhicules de police sûrement
c'est pour vous provoquer sur clicanoo
qui vous voyagez avec les chenilles et
tout ça
c'est la même c'est la blague killing le
dernier qui était qu'il est que dernier
bye le pétrole sera consommée dans un 14
16 américains dans tout inquiet d'une
flic voilà mes donc soit on est capable
d'enclencher une transition 10 ans et
fiction on va sortir on sort de la
situation de la voiture parce que c'est
pas possible de transporter d'utiliser
une tonne de tonnes 5 de matières
premières et de pour transporter 80 kg
ou un peu plus il ya du covoiturage
et ça nous rend plus heureux heureux au
sens large y compris économiquement donc
se poser cette question pas si tu aimes
c'est quoi le système économique dans
lequel n'y a pas tout ça et que ça leur
donne envie d'essayer plutôt cette
solution là c'est finalement assez long
cela pain défendre dans ses seins 1 si
on continue de se tabasser pour aller
chercher les ressources pour aller
conquérir des marchés pour continuer ce
phénomène de guerre économique cher
robert guillaume ou
soi soit on n'y arrive pas assez ça
c'est ce qu'a fait de transition soit on
continue
le jeu de la guerre économique
oui bah je peux enfin oui d'une manière
ou d'une autre je pense que ça va se
tendre alors ça peut se tendre de plein
de manières ça peut s'entendre avec
effectivement la question de flux
migratoires qui est du coup créer des
séismes politiques à gauche ou à droite
ça peut se tendre avec des questions
technologiques
d'accélération de la productivité
historiquement voilà on a toujours eu il
ya eu la destruction de la création
d'emplois enfin le voilà l'ouragan
l'ouragan perpétuelle technologique à la
chaume better ces destructions créati
créatrice exactement donc là le truc qui
comme jusqu'à présent ça marchait bien
parce que voilà j'ai détruit un peu dans
l'industrie l'agriculture puis voilà
on a trouvé des jobs de contact de
juristes et quelques autres trucs à
oxyder aussi nos besoins qui ont explosé
il ya aussi la complexité liée au fait
de plus en plus concentrée sur un
territoire ça engendre aussi des besoins
des métiers mais on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi avec l'eau
l'assainissement les systèmes de
transport et c'est
bon et donc ce truc là bas ça peut ça
peut ça peut dévier un peu parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir je pense
moi je crois pas du tout aux études
extrêmement alarmistes sur le nombre de
jobs qui pourraient être détruits par
l'intelligence artificielle où les
robots autres mais de le fêter que ça
rend détruit sa valentine et s'ils sont
trop c'est des chiffres qui sont qu'ils
sont
je sais comment ils sont fabriqués d'une
part c'est un gros tableau excel avec
des stagiaires qui mettent des
pourcentages en face de fric job avec d
une étude multi critères sur quatre
trucs c'est pas c'est pas très dur à
faire et c'est pas très sérieux
mais surtout parce que voilà c'est ça
donne des chiffres qui sont absolument
aberrant qui disent qu'il ya 95% de
chances que les serveurs et les
serveuses par exemple dans la
restauration va dire dans le
transport de personnes de fret
d'hécatombe un veto là dessus faut pas
me mettre en difficulté
non mais le fait est que ya toujours eu
de la productivité joues rouges qui nous
voilà il ya toujours eu de la de la
recherche de productivité qui a toujours
eu lieu dans des industries dans les
services partout recherche de
productivité ou de la recherche de
cupidité nom de productivité au sens
baisser les coûts en réduisant la
quantité de travail humain qui était
nécessaire pour produire une unité de
quelque chose d'accord ça d'abord été de
la mécanisation cette mécanisation est
elle gérée elle était aussi là pour
adresser la pénibilité donc pendant un
moment ça a permis à avoir des jobs
était moins dure que faisait pas creuser
des tranchées à la main ou le 2 mai 30
personnes a creusé une tranchée à la
main où était un tractopelle voilà c'est
plus facile plus rapide et une fine et
moins cher parce que la quantité de
travail
moore aurait dit max dans la sphère dans
le dos lac dans le dans le tractopelle
vont moins bref vous avez compris après
ça a été ça a été plutôt de de
l'automation il ya eu lieu de
l'organisation le taylorisme a fait
partie de ça c'est donc c'est avant tout
de l'organisation et puis ensuite c'est
l automation d'élèves et d'électronique
50 60 puis maintenant c'est le numérique
et la version numérique plus plus avec
l'intelligence artificielle donc ça
c'est une course qui ne s'arrête pas qui
ne s'arrêtera pas que ça t'a pas dans
les paramètres économiques actuelles à
quelle vitesse elle peut aller où
s'accélérer
j'en sais trop rien mais le fait est que
quand on fait ça qu'est ce qu'on fait on
remplace du travail humain par deux la
consommation d'énergie et de ressources
j'ai remplacé le guichetier de la ratp
du skieur donc c'est pas forcément un
job super bien ok très bien peut-être le
composteur d'élire le poinçonneur des
lilas non plus mon mais le fait est
qu'il est remplacé par une machine est
une machine c'est donc de la
consommation d'énergie et la
condamnation inéluctable de ressources
puisque on revient toujours à mon
histoire de nombreux cycles âge donc ce
truc-là continue et on continue dans les
paramètres économiques ont aujourd'hui
on continue à faire de la recherche de
productivité il ya deux moyens de
détruire de l'emploi s'est délocalisé
j'entends localement s'est délocalisé ça
s'est passé etc il ya des choses qui se
délocalise moins bien que d'autres mais
et puis à la productivité et en face de
ça on espère qu'à de la création le truc
est ce que demain on va tous se
retrouver
data myners concepteurs de drones et 20
pilotes de drones et concepteur de
robots j'ai du mal à 2 drood 6 3 un pub
où j'aimerais en plus non mais c'est ça
qui est génial c'est qu'en plus des
prospectivistes se perdre dans leur
propre dans leur propre prospective trop
vite parce que le truc ça fait penser je
vais y avait un débat un gain en
angleterre là tout récemment qui avait
dit on va on va vivre son temps puis en
aura plein d'autres job différents dont
conducteur de 2,2 beurre et s'était fait
bâcher parce qu'il y avait du vent dans
son temps tu es gentil ça sera les
voitures autonomes et il y aura plus de
conducteurs de pur beurre vraiment donc
il ya de la tristesse son emploi si
cette destruction après remplace pas
remplacés par de la création d'emplois
si c'est les cols blancs c'est à dire
les gars qui bossent aujourd'hui dans
les agences bancaires qu'on ferme
tranquillement à bas bruit etc j'étais à
l'école blue
whale agence broquères agences bancaires
oui c'est une toile bleue ou du col bleu
blanchi enfin mon nom me suis quand même
un peu il ya tous les niveaux jusqu'au
directeur de l'agencé enfin on pourrait
dire oui d'accord bon ok c'est pas du
goût qui sut commerçants bon voilà bon
ça va sauter ça tout ça c'est en train
de sauter déjà et puis société générale
ils sont six communes personnes
beaucoup je prends un charme combien
d'agents ce beaucoup de façons c'est les
filiales et les banques en ligne sont
les filiales des banques traditionnelles
donc pour pour la plupart donc est ce
que là ça va créer voilà on sait où
malheureusement les ouvriers employés
vote pour des raisons diverses et
variées mais con con qu'on arrive qu'on
arrive quand même à approcher et à
comprendre quand on n'est pas juste à
regarder tf1 et je pas quoi
et basse quand ça va un petit peu
comment de continuer à monter cela aussi
peut être une instabilité politique
assez désagréable quoi voilà donc ce que
pour qui
pas désagréable pour pour tout le monde
parce que voilà je perds si on voit
revenir des
autoritarismes plus plus important il
sera peut-être un peu tâté de verre
d'ailleurs parce que justement il y aura
aussi d'autoritarisme assure la vitesse
des voitures et ils ont les risques lui
c'est cuit l'autoritarisme ce sera ne
sera pas réclamé à aussi moi je pense
qu'il sera clair mais bien sûr j'ai déjà
réclamé à faire face à face au
terrorisme et c'était enfin on voit bien
que les gens sont prêts à se réfugier
assez vite enfin la question de ces pas
des données personnelles etc a aucun
problème alors voila si je n'ai rien à
cacher donc voilà un problème et donner
enfin je préfère ça que de faire
flinguer à la terrasse d'un café donc je
pense qu'effectivement c'est plus de
chance ou faire foudroyer que vous de
change oui oui maintenant j'entends bien
je disais je nage je personnalise et
j'aurais pas dû parce qu'après ses prix
et petits bouts qui sont pris ouais non
pas du tout j'ai pas du tout
d'inquiétude sur un terrasses de café
je peste juste quand elles sont
chauffées voilà mes
donc voilà donc c'est sûr que
effectivement j'ai peur que ça grince un
peu et en fait cette question de
l'emploi c'est ça qui est important fin
on voit bien d'ailleurs que l'écologie
passera jamais au premier plan c'est la
première question c'est la question
économique de l'emploi et mes enfants
est-ce que je peux me loger etc donc
alors l'emploi la croissance et l'emploi
tout ça c'est on nous le répète depuis
assez longtemps debout quand on est
petit et puis alors la croissance et
l'emploi donc il faut faire de la
croissance m'ont donc la croissance il
n'est pas si elle n'est pas aujourd'hui
suffisamment écologique dont on fait la
croissance verte retour sur le début de
notre discussion
alors un la croissance est ce qu'elle
reviendra qu'est ce que c'est que la
croissance quand elle revient est ce
qu'on l'a compte correctement ça envoie
plein de débat que vous avez sans doute
déjà lu et vu mais bon voilà si j'ai
l'immobilier qui prend 10% et un le
peler la partie de la valeur ajoutée et
donc ce qui est contée dans le pib des
agences immobilières qui prennent un
pourcentage de la valeur du bien ça fait
monter le pib sans qu'il soit passé
grand chose donc déjà tout un aspect un
peu virtuel dans tout ça et puis après
il ya effectivement le fait qu' on voit
bien qu'on reviendra pas sur des sur des
taux de croissance
comparables aux trente glorieuses donc
qui permettent un retour au plein emploi
vient d'ailleurs cette croissance ce qui
n'est pas souhaitable qu'ils reviennent
d'un point de vue environnemental
puisque on sait pas faire un découplage
les économies entre
entre de la consommation d'énergie de
ressources les émissions de gaz à effet
serre et le pib donc on sait faire ce
que les économistes appellent un
découplage relatif il ya une courbe qui
monte puis l'autre ça mais à monte
péniblement un peu moins vite donc voilà
mais je sais pas faire ça je ne sais pas
faire monter le pib est ferme diviser
les émissions de co2 et ses parts car ce
n'est pas vous allez passer voir payer
les retraites a bavé sur tout ça ça ça
explose c'est comme les retraites c'est
la même chose que les c'est la même
chose que les centrales nucléaires face
est du droit de tirage pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il ya la notion de
retraite parc par capitalisation par
répartition est exactement la même
un cancer que c'est au moment la seule
différence c'est qu'en fait je peut
capitaliser à l'extérieur de la delà de
lazoa donc je peux exploiter les béni
oui oui bon fuir si vous n'êtes infirme
voilà c'est effectivement la différence
mais sinon il fini il faut toujours des
gens il faut que je convertis son argent
en
dotation réels c'est-à-dire en travail
humain de gens qu'on fait pousser des
tomates
celui qui va me changer ma coach etc je
vous coupe une seconde une question
d'internet pour philippe bihouix la
solution face aux mensonges de la
croissance verte virgules c'est la
décroissance
où on s'arrête maintenant et on
stabilise notre confort technologique
pour l'interrogation
alors ça c'est ses doigts être stuart
mill non business sexe et l état
stationnaire dans l'huile était c'était
un des rares économistes au xixème
siècle disait faut pas forcément faire
de la croissance ça nous mènera
forcément dans le mur mais il faut faire
de la faut faire un état stationnaire un
an non l'état stationnaire ne fonctionne
pas si on ne fonctionne pas sur mon cas
de repas le tout démographique c'est ça
un moment indépendamment même de la
démographie c'est à dire si je prends
juste une population je touche pas à la
population et je reste et je hais je
partage pas a dit je reste avec les
inégalités etc je reste avec eux ce que
j'ai aujourd'hui je me crachent quand
même puisque de toute manière j'ai une
consommation inéluctable de ressources
non renouvelables d'un stock finit donc
je fini par tomber je tombe juste plus
ou moins vite
quand je fais de la croissance je me
rapproche
éventuellement d'une échéance et où
qu'elles soient et si je suis plus
vertueux écologiquement si tenté qu'il
ait pas d'effets rebonds et que je fais
plus de recyclage que je fais de la
décroissance etc
je recule c'est son recul et ou juste
ralentir enfin je je je je m'éloigne je
m'éloigne de d'un éventuel problème
mais tout ça est un peu virtuel parce
qu'à côté de ça ce prêt se présente
d'autres aspects quelles ressources r la
question de la capacité de la planète à
réguler son climat la question de la
biodiversité
la question des pollutions globale que
ce soit ce qu'on trouve dans le foie des
morses où les micros presse nicolas
willot bien aussi voilà mais bon moi
c'est moins grave que le match je
voudrais tu refuse pas voilà ce qui
s'accumulent dans les chaînes
alimentaires etc voilà donc
donc non la solution f en fait n'a pas
été design et
personne n'a design et d'un point de vue
technologique ce que pourrait être
effectivement un monde durable mais
durable sur quelle chaîne on veut durer
quoi milan ont fait durer dix mille
henri durez 500 ou l'usure et 30 déjà
c'est ça aussi la question moi je me
suis projeté plutôt dans celle ci on
voulait déjà dur et des quelques
centaines ou quelques milliers d'années
quoi en me disant parce que comme ça je
me mets extraits du débat à 30 ans vous
savoir s'il ya assez de lithium là pour
déployer un million millions 100
millions de véhicules bon c'est pas très
grave parce que je me mettrai sur les
100 millions de dhs et 10 ans suivant et
des dix ans suivant et des dix ans
suivant et très vite j'ai un problème
c'est ça qui disqualifie nucléaire par
exemple je peux pas faire même si j'ai
la génération 4 même si j'ai le les
surgénérateurs qui mangent l'uranium 238
et que j'ai quatre mille ans de réserves
d'uranium je sais pas quoi eh bien il
faut construire une centrale tous les
sens en quoi et malheureusement avec un
circuit primaire de centrales nucléaires
ont fait pas des boîtes de conserves
croyez moi je voyais les c'est bien
comme on a dit tout à l'heure donc je
vais faire quoi 40 fois flamanville tout
laissait que pour tenir 4 millions c'est
ridicule voilà donc il faut des faux
décroître après la cavité je sais pas ce
que je sais c'est que on en a tellement
sous le pied c'est ça la question de la
sobriété et c'est là où dans
l'éco-conception fin sur l'aspect du
numérique par le numérique je suis
d'accord que voilà il ya des choses
formidables en a parlé tout à l'heure il
ya des choses formidablement horrible on
va parler aussi un peu
et bon ok il ya un côté un peu bien
commun de l'humanité sur le chercheur
qui arrive à échanger des informations
génial entre l'australie et et son
collègue écossais sur la connaissance
l'accès à la connaissance bon ok
si on veut essayer comment on fait pour
faire des lots tech dans la high tech
comme en garde ça est-ce qu'on peut
garder ça j'en sais rien à un moment le
mont condensateurs autant talent il va
toujours finir par péter et puis faut un
taux de change avec un autre que l'on
s'attend au total sauf que si on regarde
bien la gabegie hallucinant de tourner
numérique je suis à peu près certain
qu'on pourrait
réduire d'un facteur
100 alors je vais être gentil avec 20 à
50 l'impact écologique du numérique
actuel tout en gardant
98% des fonctionnalités est vraiment
intéressant de terre si je me mets à
faire moins de vider beaucoup moins deux
vidéos ou plutôt de meilleure qualité de
meilleure qualité dans mais wikipédia
tout wikipedia en anglais c'était sur
deux cd alors
fait parce que j'ai pas dit j'ai pas
d'idée ils ont quand même un peu plus de
serveurs pour encaisser le trafic
évidemment mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que voilà il avait pas d'argent à
un moment ils n'ont pas fait défaut il
n'y a pas de vidéo les photos sont
toutes à basse résolution et c'était
important ça remplit voilà un certain ça
ça sert à pas mal de choses donc si on
fait pas de la vidéo si on n'est pas sur
une dictature du temps réel permanent
qui obligea d'été à mettre à jour des
serveurs et qui du coup en permanence
fondé du trafic si on est si on aime on
n'a pas ce culte hallucinant de la
performance est à dire je peux pas me
permettre évidemment quand je suis
amazon que mon site tombe pendant 3
minutes 20 secondes ou une heure c'est
la perte de chiffre d'affaires est
tellement énorme donc on va faire quoi
on va faire de la redondance énorme et
c'est la question les équipements on l'a
dit tout à l'heure le truc qu'ils sont
potentiellement non pas increvable et je
veux dire s'ils sont pensés et modulaire
et c'est sur la question de sur la
question des softwares des obédiences
yale où le fasse qu'on met sur les pages
web etc il ya eu un nombre de pistes
hallucinant et quand on met tout ça
ensemble on peut diviser par sans
l'impact l'impact alors est ce que ça
nous fait tenir jusqu'à 4000 j'en sais
rien en tout cas c'est mieux que un
secteur du numérique qui aujourd'hui
émet plus de co2 que le transport aérien
croît plus vite que le transport aérien
et nous amène dans le mur et encore ça
c'est sans compter les bitcoins quoi un
avis sur les vitrines
basse et des tulipes hollandaises
ou john law enfin c'est je pense que
même les gens qui en prennent ou même le
chicago board of trade reconnaît que
c'est un produit spéculatif j'ai du mal
à comprendre à croire que ça puisse être
autre chose qu'un produit spéculatif
après moi je connais pas très bien
l'aimer usages qui en sont faits mais
j'imagine tout à fait que c'est pas
c'est pas clean clean donc bon voilà et
puis et puis effectuant d'un point de
vue énergétique c'est c'est juste une
aberration parce qu'en fait on fait
tourner des datacenters pour rien faire
quoi finalement juste oui j'ai tourné
des proches pour les calculer un petit
peu oui ouais mais ça devient quand même
non négligeable cette affaire mais c'est
surtout quand on veut avoir une bulle du
dollar qui va se réfugier sur les cris
tout monnaies ça va
nous mettre tous les ordinateurs même
ceux qui ont pas l'habitude des mineurs
ou dave qui va être content
question d'internet c'est leur avis pour
les humains remplacé pour interrogation
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
salaire l'universel ok alors
le débat sur le salaire universel et il
est chargé j'avais j'avais commis
d'ailleurs une
une tribune pendant la prend dans la
campagne présidentielle s'est reparlé de
boulleret absolument
voilà non je t'avais s'échapper voilà
qui en fait disait qui renvoyait un peu
dos à dos amont et la silicon valley
cette année en dix ans
finalement si le salaire universelle
c'est juste une manière de dire les
robots les machines bosse pour nous et
donc dans un cas c'est juste pour éviter
que ça s'effondre parce qu'il ya trop de
prolétaires trop grand et dans l'autre
c'est je fais ça un peu sociale c'est
super parce que les gens ont perdu leur
boulot pour moi ça me ferait la même
chose et ça repose sur des bases qui
sont pas corrects qui sont le fait qu'on
peut vivre dans une société hyper
technologique hyper machinique avec des
des ordinateurs l'intelligence
artificielle partout et des robots et
des drones de livraison alors donc ça
c'est le premier lepoint fr moi je
préfère je préfère la société de post
croissance ou de décroissance charge du
poste croissance souvent maintenant ça
fait moins peur que des croissances
faibles ça passe de croissance de plein
emploi ou une pleine activité
que une solution avec des gens qui
bossent pas à qui j'ai donné salle est
ravi du coup
et puis on peut définir le niveau et
puis des gens qui continuent à bosser
après je n'exclus pas que je sais pas
par exemple
il peut garder des usines ou des
activités hyper polluantes et on
pourrait tout à fait imaginer que
voulait d'avoir le stress de fermer
l'usiné de mettre 200 mecs sur le
carreau alors que le truc qu'on sait
qu'il est néfaste après un environnement
talent on pourrait imaginer effectué en
avoir des mécanismes de d'assurance
chômage augmenter ou je sais pas quoi
bon tirage ouais ouais alors ça doit
tirage c'est pareil là c'est un peu les
permissions sur sa ce qu'est droit de
tirage en mètres carrés méfiants les
mètres carrés ils sont à neuilly où ils
sont à clichy femmes ont ça me paraît un
peu compliquée après je sois il ya des
choses intéressantes c'est à dire si je
sais c'est pas normal de papé de payer
l'eau de sa piscine et l'eau pour
prendre sa douche au même prix du mètre
cube et c'est donc tant sur les aspects
des progressivité des tarifs fixés il ya
plein de choses intéressantes à faire
alors post croissance de plein emploi
c'est dire quoi c'est dire qu'en fait
effectivement il ya des emplois qui
disparaîtraient parce qu'il ya des
activités qui sont juste les phases d'un
projet environnemental qu'on veut pas se
permettre de grandir affaire ne va pas
juste fabriquer des trucs pour pouvoir
l'acheter pour dire que ça crée de
l'emploi quand on fait engrosser la
filière des sacs plastiques en auvergne
ah là là il faut continuer dans des sacs
plastique parce que sinon j'aime être
des gens sur le carreau bon un moment
fort il faudra qu'on réfléchisse et
différemment et comment on peut faire ça
de mon point de vue c'est que on
enlevait un peu le rôle de l'état tout à
leur gilet ses terres que aujourd'hui
les tailles là encore il a encore une
puissance énorme même si on peut dire
qu'il a rendu beaucoup de choses à
l'europe etc ou demain aux régions je
sais pas il a une puissance prescriptive
normative réglementaire ce qu'en dit
tout à l'heure et je m'interdis les
voitures de plus de mu 1000 kilos
l'année prochaine et puis 995 kilomètres
d'après et puis je vais vite aller vers
la bicyclette tout en donnant aux gens
la possibilité de préparer il a un
pouvoir d'achat il est prescripteur
d'achats publics cv n'avoir donc il a un
pouvoir d'emprunt effectivement alors
dans son emprunt on pourrait mettre sur
la partie financière il a un pouvoir de
soutien à l'innovation or aujourd'hui
c'est plus facile de d'aller capter un
peu d'argent au public sur les fonds
d'avenir etc quand je suis un peu
numérique start up du résout las vegas
et achats super plutôt que quand
j'essaie d'ouvrir un atelier de
réparation de vélo je sais pas quoi bon
voilà les achats publics le contenu en
emplois d achat c'est à dire que l'on
peut dire que si je j'achète un bâtiment
ben je peux compter les heures de
travail qui a dedans est ce que c'est
des panneaux préfabriqués qui ont été
faits à l'autre bout de l'europe est ce
que c'est les artisans locaux qui
peuvent travailler donc à des questions
autour de ça et puis à la question
fiscale si on fiscal qu'on n'a pas rendu
au niveau européen adapte que ce que je
sache en tout cas et en fait on vit
pourquoi est-ce que la productivité elle
fonctionne pourquoi est-ce qu'on
remplace des gens par des machines
pourquoi est-ce que si je vais chez mon
distributeur de machines à la vie
préféré c'est plus cher de l'ouvrir et
l'essai de la réparer si tenté que ce
fait possible que d'en acheter une
oeuvre parce que j'ai fait un arbitrage
fiscale entre le coût du travail humain
et le coût des ressources et d'énergie
j'ai assis sur le travail humain j'ai
fait porter ce travail et maints le coût
de la sécurité sociale le coût du
chômage le coût des retraites c'est donc
du coup à la fin c'est c'est trop cher
mon bon monsieur et les entreprises les
administrations
nous tous dans nos actes consommateurs
au quotidien à moins d'être
effectivement un peu militant et essayer
de réfléchir à tout ça et encore c'est
dur eh bien on va arbitrer vers ce qui
est le moins cher et le moins cher c'est
là où j'ai rien assis donc c'est moins
cher de mettre à kilowattheures et c'est
que de mettre du temps ou réaliste oui
oui voilà mes donc après voilà c'est
il ya plein de calculs jancovici qui
passait chez vous l'autre jour voilà on
raconte combien d'esclaves énergétique
vous avez etc et combien peu cher et
l'énergie de david de pétrole ou d'un
kilowattheure électrique par rapport aux
avec ivan en humain mais ça ça devrait
changer ça ça me change on peut décider
demain d'aller alors ça peut être
progressif après tout il ya un espèce de
mini big bang fiscal sur la question de
la csg par exemple pour transférer ces
choses du du travail vers le capital ou
les retraités oui parce que ça donne bon
alors versus la taxe et toulon
rentrons pas dans ce débat-là mais est
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est il
ya deux choses sont possibles ça se fait
eh bien là c'est ça serait de faire un
transfert du travail humain vers ce qui
est rare aujourd'hui à savoir où ce qui
est rare ou coûteux au niveau
environnemental l'énergie et les
ressources et donc sortir du système un
peu 19e siècle où en fait on avait les
ressources étaient gratuites un jean
baptiste say les retours sont les
ressources sont réduites sinon les
aurais pas pour rien donc elles ne
coûtent que le coût du travail et du
capital pour les extraire rien d'autre
et au contraire de travail au 19e siècle
bon on avait encore quelques-uns qui
ceux qui préféraient se planquer dans
les campagnes au lieu de rejoindre
birmingham et pilote donc le travail
c'était plutôt la partie ressources
rares on va dire donc on a on a tout mis
on a tout misé sur sa et enfin avec
derrière le le xxème siècle qui avec
toute l'assurance sociale etc et
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire on a trop
de travail humain
du maillon de notre allant chômage
emploi temps partiel subi etc et on a un
problème sur les ressources et l'énergie
donc il faut changer le truc donc ce
serait en faisant ça mécaniquement si je
puis dire j'arbitre et il ya des choses
qui vont re devenir intéressante et des
choses qu'ils reviendront plus locale
qui redevient
ça coûtera moins cher de faire de faire
les choses localement et donc c'est
ainsi c'est ça permet d'aller vers un
système économique qui serait ou la part
de travail humain remonterait alors il
s'agit pas de revenir au roi et de
gandhi il s'agit pas de se remettre à 30
a creusé la tranchée
au lieu d'avoir son tractopelle donc
c'est pas une remise en question de
l'acte sur la pénibilité mais il ya une
foultitude d'emplois de proximité
qu ont disparu je sais pas
des choses qui sont fabriqués à l'autre
bout de la terre grâce à la
conteneurisation j'ouvris fait remonter
ce question d'internet concrètement la
pause croissance et coins les plus longs
hivers plus de facebook le vélo on est
pas mal moins que facebook
plus de facebook avec vidéo déjà on va y
avoir des zombies
parce que le sevrage eux facebook c'est
difficile on peut commencer par le oui
un peu on peut commencer par le feu un
programme de postes croissance je suis
patient il faut commencer par arracher
le smartphone à tout le monde parce
qu'effectivement on là ça on sent bien
que dans un univers démocratique ça va
pas te ça va pas tenir très longtemps
alors l'exemple du pull quand même c'est
intéressant parce que effectivement donc
c'est la différence entre l'efficacité
la sobriété c'est à dire que isoler son
bâtiment et continuent à me chauffer à
23 ou 24 degrés en hiver comme on
commence à faire quand on fait
maintenant
versus ne s'est pas 16 17 18 degrés il
ya quelques décennies tout ça ça bouge à
présent si oui alors oui là on est sur
wii ça dépend évidemment sinon pareil
mais dans les carpates oui dans le
château de dracula
on notait en dolby même au fin fond de
l'afrique
bon donc oui alors et la question c'est
est-ce que ces années-là vécue
par les gens dans ces années là c'est
pas si on interroge des petits vieux du
petit vieille sur les années 60-70 c'est
ce que c'était des années liberticide
est-ce que c'est des années qui voit là
est ce que est ce qu'ils ont vécu ça
comme une consommation énergétique
favoriser les libertés
la réponse est oui bah oui bien sûr
elles à favoriser les déplacements
l'état at-il le boyau de légiférer fins
aux mouvements économiques
alors je vais remplacer mouvement par un
marché ben alors saad et moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que ça dépend un peu d
de la nature des
de la nature des activités économiques
si c'est une activité économique qui ce
qui peut bouger ses nerfs je fabrique
des voitures par an
bon il ya la menace immédiate à l'emploi
enfin c'est à dire tout le débat qui
assurait taxe carbone même au niveau
européen d'ailleurs c'est ça c'est à la
haye ce que la chimie européenne va
rester compétitive est ce que ces gens
renchérit le coût de l'énergie
donc là il ya un petit débat
il ya un petit débat à voir et je vais y
revenir tout de suite si c'est des
activités locales non délocalisables
mcdonald's je fais ce que je veux avec
donald il va pas me livrer les vas pas
me livrer les hamburgers par par drones
à partir de l'espagne ou de l'italie si
j'ai décidé de lui interdire je sais pas
les emballages jetables il va bien
falloir qu'ils se débrouillent s'il veut
continuer à faire son chiffre d'affaires
donc j'ai chez un moyen théorie quant au
moins de coercition à l'extrême au
contraire c'est le numérique et puis si
je dis demain je mets une taxe sur les
data center d'aubervilliers [__] tout va
partir je sais pas ou au groenland en
chine ou ailleurs et là ça sera ça va ça
va être beaucoup plus petits à faire
marcher alors entre les enfin mon action
en fête n'aura été presque destructive
du coup alors sur la partie
intermédiaire de dire finalement tout ce
qui est manufacture industrie etc la
question c'est
celle c'est un peu l'horreur enfin pas
l'horreur mais c'est ces démos
repoussoir alors j'ai quand même les
lâcher mais c'est la question des
barrières douanières
c'est en gros c'est j'accepte ou non
d'appeler une tomate une thomas blard
douanière est peut être normative elle
peut être réglementaire où elle peut
être tarifaire des deux possibilités c
est ce que cette tomate est ce que ce je
ne sais pas ce poulet brésilien trempé
au chlore j'appelle ça un poulet ou
j'appelle passer un poulet face à des
producteurs qui serait
éco-responsable que sais-je avec des
petites exploitations magit
voilà est-ce que
et est-ce que je
jour je mets des taxes à l'entrée alors
yens il ya un peu une prolongation de
l'erreur marxiste ou marxienne je sais
pas c'était le taux de que je trouve ça
un peu chez ge encore une sensibilité un
peu écolo donc chez les marques si
c'était en gros l'érosion des taux de
profits allaient faire que le
capitalisme s écrouler de lui-même bon
on a vu ce que ça a donné et puis il a
trouvé d'autres souffle et apparemment
on en a encore pour un certain temps
alors chez les écolos il ya un peu un
équivalent c'est le prix du pétrole va
monter et donc ça va relocaliser
le prix du pétrole tu monteras sans
doute oui mais ça aurait localisé à pas
grand chose j'en ai peur parce qu'en
fait quand vous regardez le prix d'un
container qui arrivent de chine et la
conque le contenu dans son dont le prix
du transport de la partie énergétique le
pétrole peut faire x 4 5 6 que sais-je
ça va malheureusement pas remonter de
manière drastique le prix je sais pas du
trombone de la fermeture éclair ou du
parapluie au point de réinstaller les
fabricants de trombone et para plus chez
nous donc face à ça quelle solution on
as qu'on reste dans un système
hypermondialisé
reposant sur infections des transports
un peu complexe et qui sont un peu en
flux tendu dans tout ça ça aussi une une
capacité assez font pas s'effondrer mais
disons à vivre de manière un peu
difficile peut-être des perturbations
géopolitiques locales ou autre
ou est ce qu'on essaye d'avoir un petit
peu plus de résilience locale et se dire
bonjour comment ça se fait que le
bangladesh soit devenu un champion de
l'industrie du cuir 100 vaches santana
sans produits chimiques sans usine
chimique juste parce que leurs normes
environnementales et le salaire fait que
tout arrive toutes les matières
premières arrivent en container
repartant containers et finissant sac
violet dans les magasins du 16e voilà
donc je prends le violet parce que voilà
il faut teintées
voilà c'est ça ouais c'est ça la
question je pense qu'effectivement il
faudra se reposer des questions qui
fâchent alors qu'ils sont affreuses
parce que jusqu'à présent un peu comme
la croissance c'est l'emploi eh bien on
nous serine que voilà l'ouverture
croissance et la guerre
j'en sais rien guerre globale pas
forcément guerre local un peu à gauche à
droite peut-être on va dire à dire que
la la guerre c'est pratique pour la
croissance plus de dire ça comme ça
est-ce que là est ce que le fait de
chercher fort sur la croissance en fin
de la guerre je pense que celui qui
recherche la croissance par exemple le
politique qui me dit votez pour moi je
vais relancer la croissance la guerre ça
la rouge ah bah je prends je crois qu no
no no ministre de la défense
ou de l'économie se gargarise
régulièrement du fait qu' on est passé
3e ou 4e ou 5e selon les années marchand
d'armes fort technologique formidable
avec beaucoup d'emplois et de d'un étage
un trail des ingénieurs et techniciens
dedans donc le fait est que c'est pas un
secret alors on peut dire que je vends
ses armes pour ne pas les utiliser c'est
juste les gens se protègent le qatar
s'amuse pour peut-être enfin une fine et
oui je crois que on peut même d'avoir
roulé dans les salles us dont l'arabie
saoudite oui enfin bon le qatar c'est
qu'ils mouillent le terrain de jeu
s'appelle liés mais voilà enfin les
normes à tous et puis voirie par écrire
aussi on a essayé un peu dans les îles
aux heures je ne sais pas pourquoi il
fut
question d'internet est ce qu on
pourrait créer un système qui
permettrait qui permettrait que les
machines libe
l'humain du travail ou de confisquer les
emplois
je le répète
est ce qu on pourrait créer un système
qui permettrait avec les machines libère
les humains du travail au lieu de
confisquer les emplois donc la réponse
est oui c'est à dire que en fait c
si j'interprète c'est de dire est-ce que
je peux avoir un bon usage de certains
d'un certain type de machine qui fasse
que mon travail soit pas un pénible soit
sympathique soit créatif que sèche c'est
pas juste les temps modernes
voilà c'est nous et c'est pas non plus
la machine kaka piqué mon job et la
réponse est je pense oui il faut pas je
ne faut pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du
bain c'est à dire que alors je vais sur
les voilà il ya des machines je n'en
sais rien pour tourner fraiser même à
commande numérique potentiellement on en
trouve dans les fab lab par exemple on
trouve aussi les la tarte à la crème des
imprimantes 3d ans pour en tira motion
envie tu te bats tarte à la crème
l'imprimante 3d c'est formidable pour
faire des maquettes d'architectes c'est
formidable pour faire pour faire des
prototypes c'est formidable pour faire
certaines pièces aéronautiques très
complexe mais ça sera pas la grande
révolution quand on nous a promis dans
ses sorties que tout allait vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir on
fabriquera les maisons exemple et en 3d
des pizzas vos chemises et ruses pour
pour raison très simple c'est que il ya
des contraintes des contraintes
matérielles très s'inverse à savoir 1 il
faut dans une imprimante 3d il faut un
truc qu'ils font et qui sèche à qu'ils
font et où qui sèchent sous le surnom de
jeunes voilà mais il faut que ça c'est
charmant fin donc je peux pas je peux
pas broder une chemise en coton avec une
imprimante 3d il faut que j'ai un petit
bangladeshi qu'il fasse pas ce que parce
que c'est du coton avec le coton il va
passerait
alors à moins de mettre de la soie
d'araignée peut-être qu'il va sécher les
bons mais bon voilà deux ça fait du mono
matériau ou du smi multimatériaux vous
en plusieurs couleurs plusieurs super
bas met ça face à va pas monter un
téléphone portable parce qu'il faut
faire de la manu facture n'en faut
monter à la main donc voilà on peut
préférer importe quoi et donc voilà une
fois qu'on a dit c'est de trucs là il a
plus grand chose qu'on peut fabriquer un
appartement
oui alors pas parce que mono matériau
plusieurs pièces après vous allez monter
ouais ok oui
oui parce que on est dans un polymère
plastique enfin d'imprimer envers le
stick ses choix
il faut plus taper un petit morceau de
libye diaw a oui ah oui alors là c'est
la france ça sauf que ça c'est la
version avec nick wey parce que c'est
pas la cepal imprimantes c'est
l'imprimante à plusieurs millions
d'euros c'est pas la primauté à la poste
origine d'accord on arrive à la fin
notre interview on pourrait continuer
pendant des heures refaire le monde du
moins approcher notre rachat après du
coup je vais faire par macif
avait anticipé une longue interview
on arrive à la fin de notre interview je
vais demander justin et communautés pour
savoir s'ils ont encore des questions
très pressante à vous poser sur le
discorde
pendant qu'on discute pendant qu'ils
réfléchissent la dernière question qu'on
va vous poser cdc un conseil pour les
jeunes générations donc garder ça dans
un coin de votre tête pour la toute fin
donc dernière question les gars économie
basée sur les ressources pour
l'intervention possible ou pas
étranger me baser sur les ressources est
ce qu'on peut baser une économie sur le
savoir sur les changes plutôt que sur
les ressources
oui ça c'est société la star trek
oui well as idrissa berkane et de la
connaissance j'en profite pour passer un
message on a perdu idriss idrissa
berkane la dernière fois qu'on a eues il
était en partance pour la suisse et
depuis ça à partir du 25 novembre depuis
on a pu tout nouvel il a disparu
d'internet d'activité twitter il a plus
d'activité dans la presse donc on
demande à notre communauté d'aller lui
parce qu'ils trouvaient au fond
désolé pour un certain temps et voilà l
économie basée sur le cloud réponse est
la réponse est non face à veut ça veut
rien dire une fois qu'il faut pour moi
une fois qu'il faut manger une fois
qu'il faut s'habiller il faut qu'il faut
utiliser des objets du quotidien même si
on n'a pas de machine à laver mais juste
une casserole que ces fours emboutir un
faux voilà il faut réduire les oxydes de
métaux non- face et pour partie bien sûr
c'est à dire que on pourrait renoncer
sur la société du plein emploi oui je
peux avoir une suite il plein emploi où
j'ai bien plus de gens qui sont dans le
théâtre dans la créativité dans le oui
pourrait on peut faire des choses comme
ça avec ça on pourrait appeler ça la
cité de la connaissance donc tout ce
gâchis de 2 millions d'heures de
millions de gens qui qui pourrait faire
des choses formidables si peut-être il a
eu accès une autre éducation etc bah oui
ça pourrait être pour partie on peut
faire plein de choses localement plutôt
forcément prendre un avion est allé au
bout de la planète oui c'est pour partie
ça vous parle
sur internet il ya un truc
voilà c'est ça
le mouvement zaid caste ça vous paraît
un petit peu non
comme ils s'appellent le vieux monsieur
qui marie a pas très longtemps
je marque c'est tout
renseignez-vous sur mouvement ait
casques bleus ils ont ils ont un jeu pas
sur ce projet
offert du fac tchèque on est en train de
se fatiguer peter joseph ça ou ça vous
tente rarement
une autre vidéo donc dernière question
parce que ça commence à être long on a
faim la pire on doit les prendre guide
bien un prénom à bavois l'ancien accord
laissait un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose qui pourrait devenir
peut-être impérissable si on arrive à
avoir suffisamment d'énergie pour
alimenter nos datacenters ouais alors
après on fera du stockage sur l'adn il
paraît qu'en vrai que c'est bien cela
ouais mais ça c'est comment on fait pour
augmenter
stockage de l'adn on multiplie le nombre
de séquences heures c'est tout on sait
pas faire autrement donc ça sera quand
même compliqué
je dirais méfiez-vous des sirènes
technologique des des bonimenteurs
d'avenir technologique radieux qu'ils
soient de la silicon valley ou
d'ailleurs vous pensez et qui
met ce que les transhumanistes laurent
lexcellent
oui ça me parle bien sûr n'arrivais pas
à bouger voilà je les ai vus aussi chez
vous mais ça me parle mais il est pas
tout à fait sûr le sur ce domaine il
n'est pas sûr là il est pas sur la
promesse il joue sur sur la question de
la peur par rapport effectivement à
l'envahissement de lien il est un petit
peu il ya d'ubiquité dans ce que
lorsqu'il raconte donc je le mettrais
pas dans ceux dont deux paniers d'airé
kurt weill et tony sebaou un trait n'ont
pas tout à fait par contre après je
pense qu'il est fantasque complètement
je pense qu'il croit pas tout à fait à
tous qui n'y voient le vieux monsieur
c'était jacque fresco dans le bain
oui c'est bon pour les questions
philippe bihouix merci d'être venus
ainsi pour votre habitation et bien sûr
je suis un plaisir et puis on essaie de
saisir partagé dix huit mois histoire de
faire un point volontiers un coucou
groupe
[Musique]
non